une production du studio sfr
[Musique]
et mis dos à l aise sans filtre et je
saurai b à trentels sic au podcast en
espagnol
votre carlo janka
le podcast on parle de ce qu'on veut
nous inviter date je suis pas chez moi
comme plante et le haut cette semaine on
reçoit valérie beaudouin qui est une
experte une connaissance connoisseur de
la politique américaine quitte à la
radio au 98,5 avec patrik elias et
quitte à mort dit politique rdi qu'on
voit partout qui est un peu quitte à la
plusieurs photos monde embarque une
référence tant qu'on parle de politique
américaine on invite c'était vraiment
super intéressant de parler beaucoup de
contrôle des armes à feu ce qui t'a
beaucoup dans l'actualité dernièrement
aux états unis il ya eu beaucoup
plusieurs tueries de masse encore une
fois malheureusement dernièrement aux
états unis en fait qu'un nomade à tous
les jours on entend même pas parlé
donnant qui est régulièrement donc on ne
parle plus de la politique autour de ce
qu'est ce qui se passe ce qui va avoir
une réforme soir une loi là dessus on
nous parlait
john ce bon vieux temps qui est toujours
un paysage je regarde pas la banque et
noir tantôt ici le bon vieux tube qui
dans le paysage qui loge pour le morceau
qui peut être représenté dans quelques
années en 2024 ils se savaient pas de
garçons s'en cache pas on n'est pas des
fans on espère qu'il sera votre
entreprise mais qui cite donc s'opposer
on veut aller à la conversation va les
voir c'était super éclairant moi j'ai
vraiment beaucoup appris sur la
politique américaine aujourd'hui grâce à
valérie on la doit on la remercie je ne
suis pas capable de survivre encore 95
de 2000 ce chrétien
inventeur français souhaitent pop bonne
écoute sans plus attendre en fait sans
plus attendre et vous allez attendre
encore un peu parce qu'on veut les
remercier notamment du sport mais après
ce bon mot de passe monique côté what's
up les stocks est présenté par même
script nos bons amis chez mindscape
commenté de podcasts depuis longtemps
qu'ils sont toujours le fidèle au poste
pourquoi ça marche autant masquer avec
sa fille podcast c'est qu'on y croit on
croit tellement on utilise les produits
à tous les jours qui je
[Musique]
défendrai le jusqu'à la mort des
produits bentley c'est vraiment super ph
pour nous de nouveau package outils mais
moi c'est pas le tout net c'est le
platinium par kid 4.0 le platinium
package est monté devant moi parce que
c'est le package le plus volumineux
depuis le lancement de monstres et
d'écouter ce que c'est le lendemain à
4.056 et le primeur classé pour sous la
ceinture là le visage n'importe quoi on
a le oui quoique qui donne sur utilisent
maintenant les doigts que c'est pour les
polonais pour le rester clean on a le
body wash kitty moi c'est mon goto pour
la douche on a le shampoing et
revitalisant 2 pourquoi utiliser de body
qu'en disent nos clients c'est ce qu'ils
disent c'est ça qu'ils disent en plus on
a le déodorant on a le déodorant pour
les boys on hold it honneur aussi à base
ça vient avec des boxeurs que j'utilise
constamment et un sac pour voyager tout
ce avec l'odeur caractéristique de
medicaid c'est honnêtement pour les 2010
on les utilise moi c'est mon goto tout
le temps le parfum le balayage de
shampoing tout le kit qui on a un code
promo pour vous qui est ma foi au piquet
débat sans fil quand un mot pour 20% de
rabais et le shipping gratuit sauter là
dessus comme des hyènes sur la viande
fraîche puis la mise à burning up
aller voir ce même skate merci la gamme
entry merci à vous écouter vous voyez le
portugal cette semaine et présenté par
nos amis chez police lui qui sont avec
nous encore une fois aujourd'hui pour
des slips c'est une marque de matelas et
d'oreillers aussi et de
plus la base de la base de ligue 1
fabriqué ici à montréal c'est les
déménagements qui approche à grands pas
moi au moment si vous écoutez sur le le
21 moi je déménage dans deux jours puis
je change mon matelas dans mon
déménagement et j'utilise un match boli
slip avait réduit c'est quand la
dernière fois que vous avez changé votre
matelas puis dites vous que ça fait
sûrement trop longtemps
pourquoi on devrait les gens que de
recharger le matelot pour polisse ligue
la police lit premièrement il fonde est
vraiment un bon match et donc déjà ces
appareils pierre plus ignoble
premièrement la livraison gratuite
si vous avez 100 nuitées s'est occupé
dormir
99 nul à voter pour décider si vous
l'adorez ou si vous l'adorez vraiment
extrêmement beaucoup si jamais vous
l'adorez peu près du but mais vous le
retourner gratuitement
aucun frais fac et propos par une
mauvaise décision
s'ennuie c'est quand même assez
longtemps pour savoir si vous dormez
bien dans votre livre
s'ennuie beaucoup le téléfilm 40 jours
et 40 nuits c'est long très long plus
lointain de 72 à la pause en un code
promo est ce filtre pour 25% of sur
votre commande sébastien % si non
négligeable alors je vous
recommande fortement d'aller sur police
l'ip regarder sans doute commande avec
le code promo est ce filtre vous serez
pas déçus pu utiliser le code qu'on
m'ait var destruction de ce podcast
comme ça ils vont savoir que ça vient de
nous fait que merci pour les slips et
merci à vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci d'être là mais merci l'invitation
c'est parti
sans parler des états unis un
sujet éternellement renouvelables on
dirait la politique américaine c'est un
feuilleton à tous les jours on fait on
s'ennuie jamais c'est moi maintenant ça
fait pas si longtemps que ce que je suis
quand même que je suis activement la
politique
internationale mais ton métier dizaine
d'années peut-être plus activement le
pis je me suis toujours été moins se
mettront des années 80 il institue aussi
une scène à tout les jours il y avait
tout le temps c'est parce que là on
dirait que ce n'est que des
rebondissements
horrible pas parfois mais aussi
loufoques des fois puis complètement
surréel le satut toujours été sûr mais
je pense qu'ils avaient leur lot de
scandales aussi à vanter les années 70
des britanniques sur le scandale du
watergate
christelle et début aussi les gens
regardaient ça à la télé les audiences y
avait ce côté là aussi un peu où on veut
enquêter que les états unis paraissent
pas nécessairement bières
internationales avec son sexe oui en a
eu avant mais je pense qu'aussi depuis
fait barack obama s'y intéressent de
plus en plus il y avait les specs
d'attirance demande juste un mouvement
premier président afro-américain il
attirait beaucoup les jeunes va je pense
qu'au québec aussi on s'est reconnus
patate un peu plus dans les valeurs
qu'ils prônent effectué cet intérêt là
puis aussi les réseaux sociaux c'est
vivre paul avant l'on n'était pas
bombarder le les alertes la presse a
fait autant ce qui se passe aux etats
unis ce qui se passe à l'étranger est ce
qui va se passer ici donc à mon avis
c'est ce flot d'informations qu'on a
puis je veux pas les états unis c'est un
peu le grand frère leur culture c'est ce
qu'on va copier coller souvent donc la
politique c'est le même principe les les
choses comment se passe à
l'international qui vont se passer
là-bas mais ça va avoir un écho ici je
pense que notre intérêt est là et pour
l'actualité puis les catastrophes en
catastrophe ben c'est sûr que la
présidence tram vers veut pas rendre un
peu plus un peu plus ridicule parce que
je me rappelle quand j'ai commencé à
faire de la chronique je dirais presque
à chaque jour pour commenter un tweet un
moment il y en avait cinq ans de
controverses et par jour j'aurais été le
24 heures sur 24 a juste commenté je
veux temps plein de commenter des tweets
mais c'est ça parce que c'était nouveau
est-ce que tu avais vous avez déjà vu un
président ou un leader qui fait sa
politique étrangère sur twitter qui va
annoncer pratiquement quelqu'un qui est
mis à la porte sur twitter qui va
annoncer qu'il va presque à entrer en
guerre avec un autre pays sur toiture
donc ça aussi ça a changé et l'on s'est
mis à regarder les états unis perd un
peu il ya des gens qui sont mis à rire
d'eux à être moins comme acquis avant
les admire et puis là c'est un peu est
un peu gênant par moment ce qui se
passait et on comprenait pas je pense
qu'on comprenait pas que ça se passe
dans un pays qu'on a autant admiré ok ça
c c'est à dire les dernières années
quand tu es un petit peu moins rose
c'est clair que
les médias sociaux de ces justes avec
entrons dans le sujet des armes à feu
juste avec les récents événements puis
les tueries en chaîne qui qui qui ont eu
lieu aux états unis on avait accès en
temps réel à quand c'est arrivé le tipi
steppa s'était pas en revenant chez vous
le soir que tu paniers sur une nouvelle
à 17 heures ses tests en ciel pendant sa
journée de travail trois tueries en même
temps qu'ils ont cotisé en cours en même
temps j'écoutais ce matin le délit a
pour me préparer pour ces conversations
lui injecter le délit qui traite qui
honte quand même traité plusieurs fois
depuis la tuerie est hot exauce le dante
dans l'école primaire de
ce sujet là puis quand ça arrive et le
sentiment des médias sociaux que moi je
suivais ça semblait à être tellement
simple de faire une réforme d'armes à
feu c'est comme
90% des américains veulent une réforme
veulent qu'on fasse un background chic
90% du monde vole sur le moins j'ai
entendu ça je fais et 90% des américains
veulent c'est tout le monde se lève
c'est réglé puis l'heure une semaine
plus tard tu te réveilles tu sais quand
au congrès ont des besoins à faire
passer le bild si comme je l'espère en
tous genres le sport ce qui représente
les 90% c'est comment qu'on explique sur
cette espèce d'affaires le pourquoi
c'est pas si simple que les démocrates
le laisse paraître mais pourquoi c'est
pas si simple aussi d'un point de vue
canadien québec on jouerait voyons la
logique premièrement nous on irait plus
loin peut-être à dire on va bannir ces
armes
minimum est difficile y'en a pas de
législation depuis quoi à peu près 30
ans sur les armes à feu pourquoi parce
que justement tu parles de 90% mais le
10 % ils parlent fort la minorité sont
de la minorité silencieuse le médecin
l'a vu avec la pandémie aussi avait des
gens la minorité qui parlait plus
formidable on exactement mais le eux
sont sont là sont présents il ya des
mouvements des lobbys d'armes à feu que
ça soit là un arrêt pour les jambons
c'est celui qu'on connaît le plus le
guen à chauray faut associer chaîne mais
y en a d'autres aussi qui sont encore
plus à droite sport juste par les
montants d'argent qui vont donner aux
élus parce qu'il n'y a pas de plafond si
vous voulez on présent parler de 6 je
trouve ça toujours assez impressionnant
il n'y a pas de plafond des dons qu'on
peut te donner on peut donner des
millions si on veut un élu existe la
première chose à l'élu ou
bing shopping et aux candidats je
devrais plus dire le candidat mais
mettons un élu tu vas être en ré
élection mais là que tu vois que dans
ton fond il ya un million qui rendent
les centaines de milliers de dollars ou
des milliers de dollars il ya tout ce
qui est important littéralement des
enveloppes brunes en plein jour la plage
sont pas
d'accord plus posé que c'est fabuleux
viennent avec des conditions bien
entendu ils vont dire que non ça c'est
la première des choses que la deuxième
ils sont tellement bons pour motiver les
gens les électeurs parce qu il ya
vraiment un think in gh qui est vous
commencez par prendre nos armes ou le
limiter ça va aller jusqu'au bout c'est
la notion de la liberté ne sait vraiment
au coeur la constitution américaine des
valeurs américaines de dire notre
liberté ce qu'on veut le plus on peut le
gouvernement ne contrôle même pas un
petit peu ils veulent même pas de
l'assurance maladie alors tic comme un
syndic on va contrôler les armées russe
et à l'extrême pour beaucoup de
personnes donc de dire on qui vont
mobiliser les gens contre télé lui qui
va voter pour telle loi c'est ce qui
fait part aussi c'est de dire qu'ils ont
des millions membres qui vont commencer
à leur dire ben lui finalement on voit
pas le on va pas pousser pour sa
candidature la prochaine fois on va
mettre quelqu'un qui est mieux dans
notre rating parce que oui lanari tue
pas vous rend plus tu vas voir rfi donne
une note à chaque candidat
a plus si les armes à feu à tout prix
aucune restriction que c'est vraiment le
deuxième amendement le qui donne ce
droit de se défendre mais si ça presque
tatoué sur ton coeur puis le f mais
c'est quand tu veux restreinte donc même
des petits gestes comme ceux ci dessus
relations publiques qui utilisent le
fait que c'est le début de la fin pour
les hommes il ya toujours cette notion
de st paul armes c'est la personne qui
est derrière fine je pense pas que
personne saine d'esprit valley serré des
enfants de lantages primaire n'y a
personne qui est bien dans sa tête qui
va faire une tuerie mais pour moi c'est
la base mais l'âme qui cite une arme
militaire entre les mains que tu peux
t'acheter à ta fête à 18 ans qui n'est
pas vraiment plus de vérification que ça
tu peux acheter des munitions presqu'à
l'infini est-ce que ça va être plus
facile c'était des francs de santé
mentale
d'une carabine à plombs dans ton regard
des dommages des plus grands mais oui
les dommages faits le gg j'ai des
frissons à une pareille pense étaient
les enfants ovaldé je rentrerai pas dans
le détail parce que c'était notamment
scabreux mais c'est matthew macdonald
l'acteur avait fait vraiment leur
discours en frappant encore le joueur
ouais il dit c'est comme ça qu'on a pu
le reconnaître c'est comme ça qu'on peut
reconnaître des enfants parce que
tellement que ça fait des dommages ne
peuvent pas surveiller j'entendais
l'entrevue d'un prof qui ait survécu dit
le tireur a entraînement dans la pièce
il m'a tiré deux balles je tombe à terre
mais lui un corps d'adulte déjà l'oeil
il pensait y mourir et quand il revenu à
lui il y avait plus aucun enfant de sa
classe qui est en vie
c'est tout ce que tu dis quand c'est des
enfants qui eux mêmes le saviez pas d'où
un corps désiré on va faire quelque
chose parce que justement il leur est
trop puissant de se dire ben non c'est
la santé mentale la sécurité dans les
écoles toujours trouvé est un autre
problème enfin avoir juste une porte si
on a juste une porte c'est on va avoir
des gars mais là ils veulent former
aussi des ans un des vétérans de l'armée
amércaine sied pas de policiers ou de
chérif world qui veulent être là dans la
sécurité dans les écoles mais ce que je
mets jamais posé la question j'ai un
enfant du même âge à peu près que ces
victimes là jamais je me suis dit oh
maintenant l'école bas pourquoi n'y a
pas un policier pourquoi il ya pas plus
qu une porte où et pourquoi ya pas de
détecteur de métal pour l école primaire
tess pas des choses qu'on met en place
tout sur la box ou le bomb ou plutôt que
de guérir de le prévenir en fait le bon
sens pis sans plus mais différent on
dirait que je suppose qu'ils campus
d'été s'il ya bien du monde qui peut
valider l x logiquement installé
vétérans de l'armée il mettrait pas ça à
l'entrée des dégâts
c'est bien d'un enfin mettez qui arrive
au mauvais moment et les preuves qu'ils
doivent être armés qui angers vu des
reportages vous cacher leurs armes dans
le tiroir un moment donné par des
accidents c'est sacré une paranoïa
ambiante qui est pas bon sens tout le
monde il est constamment peur d'avoir un
tireur d'avoir le le fusil prêt à
nice un peu de bon sens zone à l'école
c'était comment ça faisait chier qu'il y
avait 1-1 thèse d'un incendie c'est faux
que tu sortes le dimanche
c'est quand même ok ils ont honte est le
laquais ce qu'on fait si un tee shirt
qui arrive
on dirait que c'est pas le même
mentionné le deuxième amendement puis
on dirait qu aux etats unis les
amendements sont un peu lents c'est tout
le temps pour entrer à toutes les sauces
les tirs on l'a vu dans le
rugby john dube le premier amendement ne
puissent prier comme large ce quartier
mais le des experts qui font qu'on
annonce postée
le droit de se défendre tu es la défense
peut prendre plusieurs formes puis
d'avoir des restrictions sur les armes à
feu c'est aussi une façon de se défendre
les pères fondateurs qui ont écrit et la
constitution après ça les amendements
juste des bayonnais
on était
sûr tout le monde peut tout le monde a
le droit d'avoir un couteau de chef dans
sa cuisine le titre à droite de cissé se
défendre qui ont écrit la loi en pensant
à ce oui mais non c'est pas ça puis je
pense pas qu'ils ont imaginé un jour cas
les gens pour avoir des trucs explosif à
la maison et des chargeurs qui permet de
tirer s'emballe en quelques secondes ses
anciens possible de pouvoir dépanner on
était dans un contexte justement où ces
peuples et partout il ya un gars civile
il ya des dangers il ya aussi bon boulot
pas de dépendance et les britanniques
voulaient revenir qui commence à les
attaquer donc avait cette notion de
défense qu'on peut se mettre à la place
qui comprend aujourd'hui la notion de
défense est tellement l'enjeu peut avoir
n'importe quoi à qui est ce que amp se
défendre parce que tu habites dans le ch
dans le fin fond d'un champ puisque tu
sais pas si quelqu'un qui va faire une
évasion d'un missile la police arrive ça
prend une heure qui devrait avoir une
arme chez toi c'est une chose mais
d'avoir 18 ans je reviens encore san
roque a acheté deux armes de ar 15 le
jour de sa fête
est ce que c'est le même pour moi c'est
pas le même débat c'est deux choses
complètement différent c'est paul n'y a
pas un sou pour se défendre pourquoi est
ce que tu aurais besoin d'une heure
quinze de ce qu'était un contexte de
guerre est ce que tu es en ukraine en ce
moment est ce que tu es tu eu besoin de
défendre ta maison mon blond pour aller
élargir sa au fait que des lois donc si
quelqu'un arrive sur ton terrain
stationnent en mauvaise passe son âme à
la mauvaise porte je lirai ébats cuisine
meurent parce que effectif si c'est bien
pratique si c'était la mancha femme qui
finalement est à la maison tu penses que
c'est un voleur je le tire et mettez pas
accusées de meurtre parce que tu pensais
que quelqu'un arrivait tous voulaient de
défendre dompter cette notion de la
défense est tellement large et tobrouk
ce qui est ça qu elle ait des gens ils
pas rationnel mais s'ils veulent pas
changer six voix sur comme une atteinte
à leur liberté parce qu'elle est il y en
a des propriétaires d'armes à feu sont
responsables à majorque t-il son séjour
dans notre région à l'autre je mets pas
tous les jambes je pense que aussi les
élus m'ont peut mettre tous les oeufs
dans le même panier mais pourriez
toujours des pommes pourries demande à
n'importe quoi pied oui il faut protéger
les gens à un moment donné qu est-ce qui
faisaient important il ya un père qui a
perdu son enfant à ou val d hôtes
exempts ce qu'ils disaient qu'est ce qui
pousse un important retour aux armes ont
nos enfants c'est des réflexions que je
me dis qu'il faut continuer d'avoir puis
malheureusement parce que ce que ça va
être la dernière tuerie je l'espère
j'espère qu'avec la demande sur et
impliquant des enfants n'importe quel
autre souris mais on est rendu à plus de
260 sûr et je regardais les chiffres
avant d'entrer a abandonné 6 pi et plus
de tueries de masse que deux journées en
2020 qu'est ce que je faisais les
statistiques nous à être pas là à penser
que ça va aller mieux parce que je suis
de loin la place dans le monde c'est le
pire je me sens que lui mais pour les
armes à feu ont baissé sur lequel sont
dans un contexte de guerre ailleurs
métier jeunesse au regard des pays en
europe awards si on ne pas tenir de
jeudi les pays scandinaves ya encore une
tradition chasseurs ou autres qui
peuvent avoir des armes à feu mais c'est
pas 2 en épandant mêmes ressorts puis
les gens tendaient à mes collègues
à l'achat francis langlois qui est
spécialisé dans les armes à feu qui
disait un moment donné au niveau de la
criminalité mais quand on regarde
d'autres grandes villes dans le monde se
regarde le canada la criminalité va se
ressembler mais si les hommes estime
qu'ils sont plus élevés parce que les
gens sont armés illégaux stone chicane
avec quelqu'un mettait pas un gone
peut-être que ça va se finir d'une façon
différente est que l'autre personne âgée
des deux personnes mal intentionnées il
va peut-être avoir un coup de poing qui
va s'échanger merpins un coup terrible
alors ce même l'invasion des missiles je
tenais en valois qui rentre chez nous le
gtc moi je pars en mai puis par mais on
risque de sortir de son avis la mine des
deux pas de ma
vie au moins les deux lui tandis qu'elle
suscite la grande chine où
il va peut-être partir en courant ou toi
un des deux là mais ça risque de mieux
se finir que dans une résidence ou de
les armes mais aussi il n'y a pas
beaucoup de lois pour comment on les
range les enfants le cepici pas tout
dans des écoles et les histoires d'un
petit frère qui était tiré sur son grand
frère parce que l'armée était été mal
rangées sont aussi en a donc c'est plus
large que les fusillades les suicides
c'est aussi tellement plus accessible
pour des gens qui ont des problèmes de
santé mentale donc d'avoir une arme à la
maison tout un moment est très noire bet
ça à proximité ce qu'on n'a pas
nécessairement nous à la maison puis je
faisais quelque chose un peu de cette
drôle et l'exemple mais margerie terreur
green qui est une élue à l'extrême
droite quand même aux états unis ce
parti républicain qu'un justin trudeau a
décidé de déférer pour les armes à frima
db voyons les canadiens vous pourrez
plus vous défendre si quelqu'un qui
rentre chez vous aussi un pays qui vont
vous envahir mais chez les gens
répondent bien est-ce que tu sic des
journaux pas d'armes nous pour se
défendre à la maison donc même si
quelqu'un venait m'envahir la russie
arrive de même atteint en juillet je
veux comme je veux lever les mêmes je
crée rien où je veux c'est l'armée va
être là les larmes me
comprennent pas cette notion parce que
pour eux c'est une évasion
des risques encore un pas qui je pense
pas qu'on ait la prochaine
je vais pas embarquer là dedans mais
c'est une décision cohérente ses
tortionnaires la réalité de penser que
thouars besoin d'un physique éminemment
le
séisme possibilité vraiment réel que tu
t'en sers pour tout à fait essentiel à
ta sécurité c'est ce qu'ils disent
qu'ils en ont besoin
puis la presse assez de cannes se
restreint dans des états où c'est plus
restreint parce que c'est pas tous les
états qui vont elles mettre aussi large
d etat au pouvoir restreint et samba sow
aussi faute à une bonne retraite vous
avoir une bonne raison pour avoir ton
arme à mettons avec cachet mais avec toi
en tout temps c'est une raison soit
partant d'emploi ou quand tu sors de
chez toi tu le sais devant la cour
suprême sur les ans parce qu'à new york
on trouve ce trop sévère dans l'état new
york de pas pouvoir avoir ton arme en
tout temps sans raison valable divisa
mettront une marque de famille et qui
quitte le travail des vrais port est
armé tout sopi mais finalement dans les
dans le concret c'est quand même facile
d'avoir ce permis là mais même les
trouve ce trop d'obstacles avoir ton âme
parce que je vois leur interprétation je
reviens au deuxième amendement comme
quelque chose d'absolu pas quelque chose
de restreint de prendre cet amendement
leur jeu mais ça veut dire à peu près
n'importe quoi qui implique une arme à
feu et tu es ici tous bords les armes à
feu dans le métro mais là si c'est aussi
dangereux ya tellement l'application à
ce qui ramenait ce problématique
tout de suite après la tuerie au texas
si la part du connecticut c'est que son
nom et chris méfie chris murphy qui a
comme pris le stage pour faire un espèce
d'appel à ses confrères républicaine
pour s'asseoir autour d'une table qui
ont finalement fait oui en mettant
j'imagine énormément de l'eau dans le
vin
démocrates mais et puis beaucoup de 29
ans et sa focus a été critiquée aussi
par des confrères démocrate qui dit qu'
il y avait trop d'eau dans le vin c'est
quoi finalement qui est sorti de ce
genre de bello bipartisane mais il ya
plus les vérifications d'antécédents
pour les moins de 21 ans pour rendre ce
plus difficile quand on est en bas de 21
ans d'être acheté une arme de façon
générale parce que c'est tout ce qu'ils
jouent mais nul ne sait pas c'est pas
facile d'accès par la police passait
souvent cessé lice étaient commis un
crime par exemple quand avec 15 ans donc
ça c'est les imagine que démocrate je
voulais juste interdit à tous pas tous
parce qu'il y en a qui sont aussi leurs
piètres journal politique y en a qui
sont dans un état plus conservateurs
mais qui sont démocrates quelle s des
acquis mais jusqu'au bout je vais aller
plus vers mon poste mais oui les la
logique ça aurait été d'avoir 21 ans
pourquoi est ce que tu peux t'acheter
une tu peux pas acheter de bière à 18
ans mais tu peux t'acheter une arme mais
qui ont suivi des gens quelles que
soient ses responsables pour avoir une
arme d'assaut mais pour tâcher de l'alc
pour tâcher
sais pas si je vais te dire tu peu pâlot
d'agde
métrage mais c'est ça te ferait rentrer
par exemple
voilà à l'artiste c'est ce qui est
illogique donc l'enjeu c'est pour eux
c'est trop extrême dans ses sites cette
entente là et toutes les personnes qui
ont appris à la santé mentale antécédent
criminel donc ce soit plus difficile
est ce qu'ils appellent les red fly ball
aux lillois peu drapeau de dire ben
justement tête heures passées où je sais
pas un goût de et par la loterie dit
bête et moi ça va pas bien ma santé
mentale j'ai une offre je discerne
m'acheter sap le titre rwe qui a
peut-être un problème une intention mais
d'être capable d'aller facilement
dénoncé qu'un juge puisse aller saisir
la chose qui aurait peut-être pu
empêcher la tuerie au exemple oui
lorsqu'il y avait des red flag mais dans
son entourage
étaient intimidés il y avait des
antécédents de violence qui a essayé
avant d'avoir 18 ans d'avoir une arme à
feu depuis un peu plus de la voir aussi
la tuerie dans une épicerie dans l'état
de new york qui visait les afro
américains mais la personne avait son
projet défunt d'écoles secondaires
c'était les tueries suivi d'un suicide
ou le meurtre suivi d'un suicide c'est
son projet bon c'était pas ça mon projet
d'ol land à
quelques années plus tard ben il peut
s'acheter une arme aussi pas tellement
il y avait ce qui fait donc mais c'est
tellement compliqué et difficile parce
qu'après ce vote et je peux comprendre
les dérives le bon un voisin
je mange sur l'autre
mais si cette personne soit il veut cet
individu tout va bien à lui il ya inclus
aussi augmenter la sécurité dans les
écoles c'est le petit nom en haut
républicain et investir en santé mentale
mais tout ça c'est beau mais ils vont
investir donner de l'argent aux états
pour mettre tout ça en place mais
comment ils vont le faire est-ce qu'ils
vont le faire c est ce qu'ils vont le
faire comme il faut parce qu'investir en
santé mentale on le voit que c'est au
québec canada l'international c'est déjà
tellement difficile c'est si c'est pas
qu'on crée souvent ce qui est fait donc
est-ce qu'ils vont être capables avec
cet investissement le d'aller chercher
ces gens là puis des lidd les sortir de
leur situation et maquis
des signes avant coureurs mais tu
t'attends jamais ce que quelqu'un du
jour la main façon à faire de même
excessivement dur à prévenir notre ouïe
investi sentimentale mathis souvent le
mal est déjà fait je sais pas trop
volonté et tonton circle aussi doit doit
être conscientiser et je me rappelle
d'un kop je me désole je me souviens pas
de l'état mis un jeune qui a faim de
tuerie dans une école secondaire dans
son école secondaire qui avait fait des
dessins super inquiétant et avait été
rencontré les parents avaient été
rencontrés avec beloeil votre fils les
dessins qui fait à noter c'est vraiment
quelque chose il distinguer d entre eux
n ont rien peut prendre un voulait le
renvoyer à la maison ce qui avait une
inquiétude que les parents se sont
plaints lyon dit non il va rester à
l'école lui ont acheté à staff est une
arme à feu c'est pas une armée 15 mai un
pistolet ou peu importe et y est allé y
es-tu aider ses camarades de classe à
part ça les parents se sont poussés
parce qu'il savait qui était qui était
complice de seuil à une chasse à l'homme
partout aux états unis ont été arrêtés
les parents pour trouver les parents
parce que justement il savait qu'il y
avait un fournil arme puis 2 qui avait
eu mieux rudy riou ce qu'elle l'école
est inquiète le toronto un jeune qui a
déjà des problèmes à l'école sont
capables de le voir il connaît ce qui
fait des dessins qui est des
affirmations dans ces travaux très noir
et tu achètes une arme et choisi
d'ignorer somme était un peu complice à
me qualifie c'est ce qui est arrivé dans
ce collège position leur procès mais
quand même ils ont été accusés parce que
justement y avait une complicité
ces marques là mais savoir à quel point
il n'a pas de banque belgique prenne à
ma patrie parce que des gentils quand
des ados d'été d'aider ceux des ados qui
ont dit le background
inquiétant pour finalement trouver 200
climatique nécessite suivante on entre
dans des foires si dans des foires
d'armes à feu dans des espèces de vente
de garage d'armes à feu et que ton ami
devant son arme il n'y a pas de
vérification dont pluie c'est légal pas
mal partout de le faire taxer aussi ses
pas vers fils ou qui veulent dire par
les les casinos dessinant universelle
c'est vraiment à peu près tous les codes
être capable d'aller vérifier ces des
antécédents si tu veux dans injustement
congrès de la nbaa replay qui vendent
des armes à feu à n'importe quel os qu
ils y ont pas un système pour vérifier
qui en ce moment les vérifications ces
quelques secondes c'est pas quelques
jours comme ça devrait ainsi le celui
qui avait fait la tuerie l'eau il ya
quelques années dans une église noire
nature weston qui est un suprémaciste
blanc qui avait tué plein de personnes
devaient lui justement y est allé pour
une arme à feu et lyon il devait faire
le background chèque plus élargi
finalement ça prenait trop tant pis y
ont donné son arme mais normalement
s'ils avaient attendu l'espèce de trois
jours pour vérifier jusqu'au bout mais
il aurait pu on aurait pu éviter la
tuerie patate
monkey mais après tout ces événements
l'oeuvre on prend nos mails à des
centaines et rien que vraiment changé
c'est ce qui à chaque fois que ça arrive
je me souviens tu es dans le temps
d'obama c'est pareil chaque fois qu'il
vient de tir il ya vingt dix co
t on on disait qu'il n'avait pas de bon
sens quel point il faut que les choses
changent mais au final entrée séjour la
marmotte a changé jamais rien qui change
pim man city des lois qui ne se discute
en même temps passez vous est le réel
changement il paraît un changement qui
la propose j'écoutais un temps justement
aux délits y est allé le saluer leur
fille pour discuter de ce puits lui
disait il faisait pas avec toutes les
autres changements sociaux il ya aucun
changement social que commencer avec
tout ce qu'ils revendiquaient ou est ce
qu'une loi ne pas sous ce que l'hôte
absolument tout ce que tu veux
directement avec lui dit avec ce blog
est quand même historique parce que là
on s'assoit puis on discute de les
affaires qui vont sauver des vies
littéralement notre c'est sûr que ça va
fonctionner à petit ou plus grand des
minima au moins au minimum 10 au moins
là on va rentrer là dedans puis leur
peut-être éventuellement les
républicains ont fait un crime peut-être
que j'ai pas perdu de vote peut-être que
je me fait réélire même si j'ai voté
pour ce bel le peut-être que le au fond
d'eux mêmes voudrait pousser plus
piccoli se rend compte qu'ils ne sont
pas vraiment en danger de perdre leur
place perdant leurs financements
vertisoft peut-être que ça va ouvrir la
porte à d'autres discussions éventuelles
oui c'est possible mais ça prend
toujours été sans rentrer dans les
techniques c'est sur 100 sénateurs sont
à prendre 60 qui votent pour qu'une loi
puisse se passer l'an ce moment il ya
cinquante démocrate 50 républicain ça
c'est le
ppt les démocrates ont la majorité parce
qu'on le voit de la vice présidente qui
rentre là dedans mais quand même c'est
difficile jacques s'entendent pas tous à
100 % bien cdu 7,2 faire par ces choses
le problème c'était quelqu'un qui veut
des restrictions plus sévères c'est
clair les élections de mi mandat sont en
viennent à l'automne et les sénateurs
républicains risquent d'être majoritaire
donc est-ce qu'ils vont même proposé
parce que le leader le dit senna c'est
lui qui décide de mettre sa femme quelle
loi vont être discutés est-ce que ça va
dans ses priorités dans sa liste
d'épicerie des remèdes soho à l'agenda
pas nécessairement c'est même ça serait
assez surprenant donc il ya un momentum
la de le faire maintenant parce qu'après
ça va peut-être être autant et tente où
tu parlais des démocrates donc la
plupart devraient avoir vouloir des lois
plus sévères je pense que monter l'ange
de 18 à 21 ans ce c'est quand même
quelque chose qui est assez consensuel
exemple empêcher les armes d'assaut cet
arrivante 94 et 2004 maintenant dix ans
pas d'armes d'assaut et le problème
c'est que après avoir passé cette loi-là
la chambre des représentants qui étaient
majeurs table des macros depuis des
décennies et passés aux mains des
républicains pièce c'est justement parce
qu'ils sont allés trop loin alors est ce
qui me refaire ses calculs politiques un
peu suicidaire de dire on va trop loin
puis on perd nos élections ça risque et
c'est de la politique qui sait des
humains mais c'est de la politique donc
cesser d'ici là imaginer que mon enfant
puis dans cette zone et le ce qu'on a
remarqué une différence en terme de deux
tueries en terme de moeurs parents
mbassou dessus ça n'est pas qu'elle est
une sous valéry comparses qui en a qui
sont à céder de plus conservatrice qui
vont dire bon on peut pas le prouver
hors de tout doute que ça a changé
puis d'autres après réalise à quel point
on a évité des meurtres des tueries avec
avec un plus grand nombre de personnes
qui sont décédées parce que les armes
d'assaut justement n'en parlais tantôt
c'est plus facile et qu'est-ce que les
gens qui ont des problèmes qui ont
décidé de faire des deux passent à
l'acte sally's ont pêché non parce qu'on
touche pas la santé mentale on touche
pas l'accès aux armes de façon générale
mais au moins y avait pas sans
circulation encore plus grande l'autre
affaire c'est que les gens qui en
avaient déjà pouvait les garder c'est
juste que tu fais part fabriqué tu fais
pas aller en acheter des nouvelles mais
si tu en avais people les gays ton
enfant il y avait des dispositions qui
rendait sa possible quand même des
changes y en avait encore en circulation
donc ça réglait pas tout le problème
donc c'est assez mitigé mais disent que
oui c'est des années plus tard là qu'on
regarde les statistiques il ya quand
même eu un effet qui était bénéfique
pendant dix ans au nombre des décès au
nombre de blessés ou de dommages que ça
aurait pu s'arrêter faire
jeu malgré cette hausse malgré les
chiffres
n'est pas le cas de l'australie aussi ou
est ce que c'est et complètement
interdits finalement et dans les années
90 tuerie si je me trompe pas dans une
école y ont décidé de l'interdire après
et en nouvelle zélande la tuerie dans
deux mosquées là où il ya une crainte
cinquantaine de mars avait pas très très
longtemps à christchurch est la première
mini cela balaie dit non c'est terminé
il ya ceux qui se pensent bien
pratiquement lendemain on va interdire
les armes d'assaut dessous et au canada
je connais pas la législation est édité
par coeur mais c'est arrivé un des
événements on le voit nous mêmes
envolées j -ferry quand ça arrive même
pas dans six dans notre cour arrière
mais c'est pas chez nous un fake c'est
des endroits plus libéraux plus
progressiste que les états unis où c'est
quelque chose qui était vu comme une à
l'extrême vu au contraire qu'il est venu
là la première ministre la nouvelle
zélande n'est pas très longtemps est
venu juste après la tuerie je pense que
c'est vraiment un hasard qu'elle soit là
à ce moment là bas les gens rient un peu
d'élan glandier comme musset des firmes
qui s'était pas ce n'était pas quelqu'un
ce n'est pas un exemple à suivre
nécessairement mais justement accueil
l'australie je pense que depuis ces
réformes le sacrement change la baisse
par bing a bien quitté l'argument de
dire le problème ce problème de santé
mentale par m2 guynemer toussaint
il enlève cette diminue drastiquement
nombre de maires par goal com c'est
logique desire me promenais santé
mentale ailleurs et la criminalité il ya
des gens qui sont défavorisés il ya des
gens qui sont sans moyens il ya de la
violence il ya des gangs de rue il ya
tout ça mais pourquoi ce qu'il y en ait
plus de morts pourquoi il ya plus de
tueries de masse mais parce que plus
d'armes en circulation
et ils font tellement un marketing ont
cité le
le banc donc l'interdiction pendant dix
ans des andes aso a précisé devenue
tellement populaire
tu peux acheter ton r15 mot pratiquement
ballet et trucs des foires d'art
marzouki ti-jean à prêter de petites
tables qu'être humain dans ta sacoche
d'un sac à main ils font une publicité
les enfants qui existent un peu
caricatural mais c'est vrai les les
photos des cartes d'honneur de certains
élus qui ont des armes à feu les enfants
dans les mains pour démontrer son plein
excusez moi de choisir un faux cul aux
autres en volant des cars ne prendra pas
me donne à mes enfants il y en a environ
dans les mains puis on va leur montrer à
tirer dès qu'on va pouvoir le faire
c'est sûr est arrêté on ferait ici pis
si c'est juste aussi si c'était pas au
rip très risible quel point c'est
ridicule je pense à sa famille c'est
pratiquement le soit arriverait chez
nous dans l'est dans les heures qui vont
suivre pour leicester c'est pas quelque
chose qu'on trouvera normal mais c'est
quelque chose qui culturel qui est entré
dans qui est ancré pardon dans
l'histoire cette tradition-là donc pour
ecco2 lot de larmes pour se défendre
c'est que c'est quelque chose qu'il y en
a que ça fait partie de leur identité on
avance
mais il y en a beaucoup de propriétaires
d'armes à feu qu'ils vont dire ben moi
je suis pour ces restrictions le sait
juste qu'on les entend pas
nécessairement par l'effort mais si je
comprends la majorité des prêteurs dans
ma rue sont responsables mais n'empêche
que même si tu es responsable à quel
point tu as besoin
quand même quelque chose là-dedans de
même si tu prends toutes les précautions
et même si tu es t
pourquoi tm se à ce point là c'est
pourquoi les gens aiment ça ce point
nous mais c'est quelque chose que je
peux pas concevoir et cacherai pas que
j'ai pas d'armes alors j'ai pas cet
appel je peux pas le comprendre et rice
a toujours été comme ça dans leur
famille d'avoir ce il y en a beaucoup
c'est des chasseurs des collectionneurs
je pense que c'est ce que la pensée
derrière mais aussi un mouvement je les
ai vus sur les réseaux sociaux il ya une
petite vague sur techtoc sur instagram
de gens qui allaient donner l'horaire 15
volontairement au poste de police bondir
moi je vais la donner parce que je
réalise avec tout ce qui se passe que
j'aime pas besoin de ça donc c'est plus
flexion là je pense qu'elle est là pour
certains désirent c'est quoi je vois je
me filmer pour inciter peut-être
d'autres personnes c'est pas le
gouvernement qui vient chercher mon arme
à feu c'est moi qui dis ex passe était
libre je prévois un voleur qui vient
prendre mon art 15 pour fermeture et
après donc un espèce de sens de
responsabilité il y en a un dans une des
vidéos je me souviens dit j'ai déjà eu
des idées noires puis passait vraiment
le juste à côté de prendre mon arme à
feu rapidement prendre un mois ou un
proche le si j'en ai peuvent bien j'ai
pas cette tentation le qui va être le
pilote ici prend même tout seul il n'y a
pas les mêmes idées noires mais ils on
sait jamais ça peut revenir donc j'aime
mieux les données les remettre de façon
volontaire ce je trouve que c'est des
mouvements qui sont qui devrait on
devrait en parler plus puis ça devrait
circuler dans les médias aux états unis
de dire qu'est ce qu'un gouvernement le
quitte à les voler les armes c'est
vraiment un gars qui est décidée parce
que c'est souvent des hommes qui ont ces
armes là sans vouloir faire le
stéréotype ça reste que c'est quand même
ce statistiquement parlant qui vont
aller porter l'horaire 15 speed the run
j'en ai pas besoin que finalement je
dois bien me lever demain matin je
savais que ça va être connecté à mon arc
j'avais déjà entendu un but d'un
humoriste américain j'oublie son nom le
pays par les armes à feu du fesf est de
rendre mes relations qu'ils etc
c'est la seule raison pourquoi
quelqu'un qui dit que c'est pour la
sécurité tout excès pour des espaces qui
t'aiment l'igad qui pour la tunisie
c'était besoin d'un gones pour te
défendre chez vous
stadistes ont gagné tout le temps pris
un petit bain n'est pas la petite et est
à la portée d'un accident rend
facilement plus près cet étonnant -
mangani tout le temps tout en décharge
et dans un coffre-fort km et je le cite
en exemple des missiles terre et à
douvres et un coffre-fort défendre ses
fonctions pour faire l'avocat du diable
série du gan c'est le fun quand il
allait tirer au pigeon ses autres c'est
quand même le feuilleton tendent la
traite quelqu'un de gens recommencent à
faire qu'il le regarde et mettons le
type de guns de fer seconde l'a
peut-être d'envoi il ya moins de sam sam
défense - des bolides c'est comme un
intérêt que tu peut embarquer six effet
responsable main c'est qu'avec ce qu'on
peut
comprendre pourquoi ça intéresse
absolument sûrs c'est le fun choqué les
retraites gones qui ont l'art et iphone
qui je le sais sûrement un feeling
incroyable mais comme
souhaitant pas lâcher feeling incroyable
ce qui saute en parachute rhdp là dessus
mais ce temps kadhafi et encadrer les
actes gratuits
quelqu'un saute en parachute tu peux pas
ôter non mais s'il pouvait maintenant
c'est acheter un avion qui pouvoir le
faire chez vous attend quelqu'un de
vraiment sur le parachute le tuer puis
qu'il ya le droit de s'acheter un avion
puis quand ça beau les vacances à
magasiner les parachutes pis pour toi
qui le
mettait mal est tirée du gain tester une
belle quand tu connais pas comme gisèle
et les lois parker au canada mais
faut voir si ces bars et surveillé 24
heures sur 24 et decameron ya un système
les gens sont organisés bleuté pour les
jusqu'au 9 je connais des gens qui ont
qui ont déjà tiré plutôt si je pense que
de selon ce que c'est quoi le feeling
mais il faut que tu sois dans ta petite
l'étude sert à tel endroit petit peut
pas sortir avec qui je vais aller
m'acheter une bière puis à traîner
m'entraîner mongol ça marche pas comme
ça donc à la limite c'est une passion ce
qui je crois aussi que qu'elle est aussi
bloqué que ça t'intéresse et en inde
pour l'histoire ils veulent avoir des
armes parce qu'ils ont acheté une arme
qui datait de ses chais pas deuxième
guerre mondiale peu importe soit tu la
mets vraiment bien chez toi très très
sécurisé où c'étaient des hommes plus
dangereuse mais dans un club de tir
effectué good trip et de nausées mais tu
le fais mais c'est encadré dix essais
sont aussi qu'ils s'accrochent pour moi
aussi comprendre à la limite qui ont un
attrait mais si tu le fais comme dans un
peu un sport ou une activité non de ceux
chez toi
tgc 1% le tome deux mamans il ya des
hommes puis dites moi j'aimais ça allait
tirer c'est y ait des envies de chance
je pense qu'un autre ces dames mais j'ai
habité chez mes parents et pendant je
sais pas combien d'années puis j'ai
jamais vu chez même pas son hochet même
payet ou l'endroit où il va lui cacher
axe pour te dire à quel point que
yamissi d'un apport il sort pas là c'est
comme un espèce de collection qui quand
on y allait à la chasse à l'époque et
kbc armes mais j'habitais que ce n'est
pas la seule que j'ai jamais vu les lots
sur les oreilles et c'était tellement
bien cachés taxe est possible de le
faire de façon sécuritaire exploiter pas
anti
chasseurs ou anti personne qui a des
hommes c'est jusque ici c'est un premier
santé mentale va énormément te pas un
accès cela base cité choisir tu as eu
des idées noires pendant des années
était un problème par exemple des
schizophrénies qui peuvent te rendre
très impulsif europe je ne sais trop
bien il ya quand même des balises c'est
ce qu'on devrait avoir aux états unis
logiquement mais la logique et la
pratique moi exactions et trop puissant
et trop lucrative le ccc culturel c'est
historique qui en soit depuis toujours
ils disent pourquoi loges et enlèverait
fait qu'à chaque année c'est de plus en
plus puissants à chaque année c'est plus
en plus attrayant parce que tu veux la
dernière arme sur celle qui donne dans
la foi avait la larme hello kitty pour
revenir l'exemple de bordeaux
lille et hollywood au sikkim et après
c'est le goût de gaye avec l'armateur ya
toujours 10 et ce jour aux états unis a
good girl gone jeu pour arrêter un bad
guy legault s'est passé parce que soyons
des vestes pare-balles un truc tactique
qui arrive de ton pistolet telle me
garder une sécurité dans les psys de
buffalo où il ya eu là la tuerie visant
des afro américains n'est mort parce que
le globe est une arme beaucoup trop
puissante puis et vestes pare-balles
donc même si le dire un petit pistolet
puis c'est sa fille tête quand tu es
habillée en tactique c'est difficile
aussi des classes et à moins d'être
vraiment chance sur mille de super bien
viser juste un ancien policier c'était
quelqu'un d'extrêmement respectant la
communauté qui étaient là pour sécuriser
l'endroit pin quand même il ya eu cette
souris l'a donc même s'il y avait un
goût de gaye pas que c'est quoi la
prochaine fois faut mettre quelqu'un
avec pratiquement
ouais
c'est fou plaque dans le fond dans les
prochaines semaines on va savoir qu'est
ce qu'il en est du pays
probablement oui normalement ça devrait
passer parce que c'est un groupe de
vingt et vingt sénateurs qui
cette entente là disent républicains des
démocrates tantôt vous rappeler ça
prenait 2,10 républicain du côté des
démocrates pour que ça passe donc déjà
l'est et les dix qui sont des
négociations qui vont voter pour tes en
business par contre ça peut tomber l'an
ce moment la négociation c'est ce qu'ils
appellent le boyfriend ou pro parce que
si la violence est exact citons
historique de violences conjugales il
donnait gisent encore récemment une
fille qui allait porter plainte parce
que son ex conjointe il avait déjà
étranglés il avait menacé tout ça donc
lui il pouvait pas voir dames avec elle
mais c'est quand c'est ton ta
fréquentation ou qui t'habite pas sous
le manteau des pommes mariée sans enfant
un bel os tu peux avoir une arme à feu
même si tu étais un danger pour ta
conjointe ici si tu fais juste d été où
tu habites pas encore ensemble et en os
que justement il ya eu accès à l'armé à
feu parce qu'ils aient non je suis marié
avec cette personne d'âge
[Rires]
mais c'est un exemple lui la nouvelle
conjointe est là le pôle et la chance
que l'autre avec qui vivaient
de survivre alors c'est ça aussi qui
dérange parce que les disent que ça va
trop loin mais c'est pour nous une
logique qu'on en rit aujourd'hui en se
disant ben voyons donc le destin
historique de violence avec les femmes
pourquoi est-ce que tu as une arme
africain est en couple avec quelqu'un
qui provoque un danger violence
conjugale ou peu importe donc ces genres
de choses qui accroche mais ce que ça va
passer oui l'autre étape après chambre
des représentants ils doivent voter
aussi l'oeil des gens progresser ça
comme alexandrie au casot cortese qui
aimeraient qu'on aille beaucoup plus
loin mais selon les déclarations car le
fait jusqu'à maintenant va voter pour en
disant si c'est un vrai pas dans la
bonne direction que un but puis qu'on au
moins cet instinct petit un baby sitter
mais qu'on le fait a dit je vais voter
peau même si ça ne me satisfait pas il
ya quand même une chance et byden même
chose il doit signer apposé sa signature
pour que ça soit un web et il a dit oui
ça va pas assez loin est-ce que ça va
empêcher toutes les tueries n'ont donc
mais je vais le signer quand même parce
que et c'est un peu la même chose la
même logique dans la bonne direction
c'est évidemment qu'on parle de
de ces cultures le des gones puis
l'attrait des américains pour les gones
c'est pas tous les américains une
antipathie tout c'est surtout dans
certains et hop il surtout les pression'
allemands ceux qui votent plus
républicain et ceux qui sont plus à
droite se met il semble vraiment avoir
un espèce de de castres complète en fait
le entre ceux qui sont pros gones et
antigone oui qu'est ce qui fait en fait
qu'est ce qui fait d'eux semble être le
cas ceci est un exemple même tendance
alors que c'est pour surtout des gosses
sur toutes les questions puis peut-être
qui a été sept ma question pour
intervenir sur d'autres sujets mais
qu'est-ce qui fait comment consent
mirande il aux états unis d'être aussi
divisés sur 50 ans agressions 50 me
direz sur presque tous les anges mais
depuis les années 70 la partisanerie est
à l'extrême sa vente avait des gens même
dans les élus fait les gens qui vont
regarder les leurs élus voient même pas
qu'on est capables de s'entendre donc
déjà est un exemple qui est à l'extrême
l'effectuent un système qui fonctionne
en deux parties politiques 17 mai dans
les extrêmes ce ton parti va plus de
votre jour un peu plus loin tu vas aller
un petit peu plus loin aussi dans tes
convictions le problème c'est que les
démocrates exemple sont tous en plus à
gauche les démocrates et les
républicains de plus en plus à droite
des gens dans le milieu mais en a de
moins en moins il y en avait des
centaines avant le temps de moins qu'à
planter dans le milieu des plus
pragmatiques ou autre vtt presse que
l'ennemi de ton parti et que ce soit
chez les démocrates chez les
républicains il ya des deux sénatrices
et républicaine qui votent souvent comme
les démocrates susan collins fille lisa
murkowski
ils sont détestés d'une partie d'une
frange de leur parti politique c'est
difficile vraiment le politiquement de
décider que tu votes de l'autre côté
avant le faisait beaucoup plus souvent
mais maintenant le seuil est la risée
c'est tellement polariser les chaînes
ici on parle tantôt de la commission
d'enquêté la fille de dick cheney
l'ancien vice-président qui a voté pour
destituer dans l'autre chambre elle est
si on nivelle rien savoir d'elle parce
que justement un trou et à l'autre
extrême du passé qui souhaitait pourtant
le si la fille la plus conservatrice à
peu près dans le site une idée de la
république et hippiques le qui veut
qu'ils votent sur des enfants très à
droite est là mais c'est ça on est pas
la risée dans les états la même chose
parce que tu vois c'était un républicain
très pragmatique centre mais se voit le
parti démocrate qui pour toi est trop à
gauche soit voté républicain quand même
parce que c'est le moins pire power qui
ont pas de choix qui est clair que ça
fait que l'autre partie devient peu
l'ennemi ou six parce que le discours
est et ce qui va toujours à l'extrême
donc qu'il ya une cassure c'est triste
parce que moi j'adore les états unis
puis trouve ça dommage à quel point sont
pas capables de se parler sont pas
capables de se comprendre que c'est
tellement noir ou blanc il n'y a pas de
zones grises et ne sortent tellement
beau double féminin la faune oui y'a pas
de façon non c'est le sait le système
électoral qui favorise un
kit qui est juste deux parties comme ça
oui c'est la façon que ça ne va pas
directement aux états unis tétouan vote
indirects pour des grands électeurs qui
après savoureux voter une deuxième fois
pour vraiment simplifié s'appuie c'est
souvent un système de oui notez comme
fait si tu peux pas pas comme ici
c'était de majorque mantel
circonscription ou un thé ça donne des
ça donne 10 d'un nombre d'élus pour
après se former un gouvernement ici à
dubaï dit on gagne par deux voix et je
sais pas l'état de new york et les
gagnerait pas plus de voir ce qu'elle
sait pas moins très bon exemple
affiliées l'étude mais arrêtons là
georges il gagne par deux voix bella au
complet avec des jeux lot et c'est si
facile un indépendant ce sera
extrêmement difficile d'aller chercher
un état au complet ce que deux zétats
seulement sur 50 qui ont passé système
lequel mène et le nebraska les autres
qui fonctionne tout et nantes et caen
donc si toi tu es un indépendant ou un
autre parti le parti vert entre autres
le web qui veut faire ça
provient pas de vote soit jamais eu puis
tu en a quelques-uns qui gagne comme
indépendant mais ça va vraiment pas être
au niveau national ça va être beaucoup
plus difficile il y en a à travers les
années aussi qu' on sait dire peut-être
c'étaient des paroles vont fonctionner
il ya eu toujours la menace que dans
l'antichambre soient indépendants s'ils
partent républicain rejeté sa
candidature pour
2016 la nation
mais dont qui s'est passé mais c'est
extrêmement difficile parce que tout le
système électoral qui comme toi donc
comment est ce que tu veux le faire fait
choisir entre les deux pour ce qui est
toujours les indépendants qu'on va aller
chercher puis je me rappelle j'étais
allé pour les élections du monde en 2018
en floride puis par là des québécois qui
ont la citoyenneté qui peuvent voter il
y en a beaucoup qui étaient des
républicains pis si lyon est élevé au
québec et avec des valeurs québécoises
plein voyait dans l'antichambre c'est au
niveau du traitement avec les femmes
avec plein d'autres affaires qui il
disait c'est quoi je veux quand même
voté pour lui parce que au niveau fiscal
au niveau économique je me reconnais là
je me reconnais pas du tout chez les
démocrates qui est je dois payer trop
d'impôts ben ça m'intéresse pas pantoute
donc j'ai pas le choix puisque même
fermé les yeux sur tout ce qu'au niveau
social made hermange que ça soit l
avortement que ce soit n'importe quoi
c'est la gestion des migrants et comme
on prend par les plaintes des sujets
sociaux il se dit je me ferme les yeux
parce que où je me bouche l'année où
tout ce que voulait comme expression
parce que de l'autre côté c'est un maroc
je me reconnais pas assez actifs cdo s
ils vont prendre celui le moins pire
pour eux pas que ça donne mais résultat
que ça donne aujourd'hui vice et c'est
ce qui rend des fois difficile de faire
des prédictions parce que tu es des
indépendants qui vont aller d'un côté ou
de l'autre des indépendants et des
républicains plus modérés qui ont voté
pour dubaï de la dernière fois parce que
dans mon job c'est trop à l'extrême pour
eux il y avait encore un peu d'être
américain avec lui et qui sont dit on va
aller avec e.on kodjo qui est qui
connaît la classe moyenne vie qui va
être moins pire donc qui par un bernie
sanders qui est trop et qui book 3
gauche pour eux ou donc aux états unis
car si je me trompe mais les lillois
niche au vooruit avec des votes qui des
gens qui votent juste pour une a formé
tant que tu une position ferme en
guillemets contre avortement et puis que
tout le reste je ne reconnais pas dans
le parti mais toi / c'est non négociable
de ça ça fait c'est une bonne partie du
delta je pourrais pas dire si si j'ai
pas de statistiques pour tradition ou
l'autre mais je pense que sur des trucs
fondamente hic très fondamentales comme
l'avortement pour des gens qui sont très
religion un exemple mais ça va être
quelque chose qui va faire qui sait que
c'est aussi ton seul choix cette année
que oui ou non le top16 kiwi peu un
parti qui n'ont pu je fais ton choix
non là le truc qui comme ultra important
institut que le reste est pas j'ai pas
d'accord mais souvent ils vont voter je
devrais j'avais à faire une majorité la
plupart novotech leur portefeuille pour
l'image un peu que je fais tes c'est
souvent quand les finances vont pas bien
pour toi c'est quoi qui est plus
important niveau aussi par exemple
assurance maladie c'est obama qui à
l'époque pour pouvoir avoir accès à des
soins de santé qui ont d'immenses en
pâte endetter si c'était malade et c'est
un cancer si tu tombes enceinte savons
enfin bref tout ce que ça va être des
dossiers un petit peu plus non
négociable pour pour certains après ça
tu vas sur tellement de choses tout vote
sur le président mais tu peux voter pour
un président un exemple républicain mais
sur une sénatrice démocrate parce
qu'elle est plus modérée sur d'autres
affaires un shérif républicains dont
juge qui autre chose ton procureur après
sept ans secrétaire d'état parce qu'elle
soit c'est plusieurs pages dans les pays
candidats et c'est vraiment pas comme
nous c'est très simple ce vote pour un
parti de le député qui est le québec ait
lieu c'est vraiment vraiment différent
donc je pense que c'est un peu la beauté
de leur système parce que c'est même si
je pourrais moi m'identifier un parti x
mais le député keith prison qui n'ont
parti je les aime ce qu'il fait des
bonnes affaires je me reconnais dans sa
personnalité dans au niveau local qu'est
ce qui est fait dans ma municipalité
donc je vais voter pour lui puis après
ça je pourrais voter par exemple pour le
premier ministre notre parti on n'a pas
cette chance là ici que eux peuvent
avoir donc ce c'est comme le côté qu'on
en parle moins mais chose qui est bon de
leur système parce que tu vas vraiment
avec l'individu avec ce que ces
individus là votre présenté comme
programme t'es pas obligé de voter tout
républicain ou démocrate
tu peux aussi très variés à l'élection
on a de la misère à prendre position sur
place et à prendre connaissance des
positions de toutes les enjeux des six
pour lesquels on veut tu vois mal
comment on serait capable de prendre
connaissance et faut que ce soit pour
jouer un électeur est clairement sa
beauté à niveau comme et et de façon
éclairée haqqani volé ce qu'ils sont
tous aussi et du kit
devrait dans un système parfait
et c'est pas comme ici le spa tous les
électeurs c'est en a qui vont voter pour
un parti vivre ce soir d'un monde qui
est le premier ministre ils seront pas
nécessairement petit jeu c'est ça c'est
les problématiques d'un peu partout sur
la planète des modèles nous aurons mon
truc
c'est sur elle que oui
enfin parlons parlons de
dans notre forum pourrait qu'on peut
parler aussi des parle parle à la bande
des attaques au capitole puis de west
qui on en est rendu là dedans on dirait
que le spectre le spectre de donald
trump est jamais vraiment parti le
disparu pendant
trois quatre mois plonk ans et entendre
des échos du genre à tata qui va revenir
puis on dirait qu'il ya encore de la
place sur son terrain de golf avec télé
lula à chaque fois comme il tente en sus
d'une oreille de l'autre oeil tintin
comme on eu des témoignages de ses
proches pendant les assauts du capitole
qui disait qu' il ya des cartes en
existe à la fois vraiment intense qui
est comme il y aurait participé à
essayer de renverser le gouvernement par
les armes perd même temps tu continues à
entendre le fait qu'ils aient peut-être
locke key qui continuent à planer les os
condamné à gaza que ça n'a pas de bon
sens voudrait que je pas sûr que je suis
prêt je trouve pas ce que je serais
capable de france à travers quatre
accords
après les trois à combien de vies bleus
qui ont rien à voir avec les américaines
me tuer mais genre pour ce que je
connais de rebondir
je suis d'accord que moi j'aurais
beaucoup de travail s'il a passé un très
bon employeur par de coutume qu'un
créateur d'emplois commun comme je
l'appelle pour les gens vont dans le bon
sens pour ça je vais lui donner le ch
comme je le remercie à trois jours est
pratiquement pour ça mais sinon ça amène
énormément de dégâts de ces fonds c'est
à une présidence comme ça ça attire
beaucoup de jus l'ossature jus pour moi
puis je pars radio a parlé de ses tweets
espèce de pression mentale quand tu
parles toujours le négatif ça fait que
je pensais un peu un peu tout le monde
dépendamment du milieu dans lequel on
travaille mais talentueux qui est
toujours là il ya toujours une influence
vraiment importante en ce moment on le
voit parce que on est dans les primaires
pour nommer en fait c'est que les
parties vont nommer et qui va être leur
candidat républicain ou démocrate pour
l'élection de mi-mandat qui s'en vient
parce qu aux états unis était toujours
en élection c'est une bonne année où il
n'y a pas eu rien qui se passe il ya
toujours une élection donc le en une
grande élection qui arrive en novembre
et c'est pour ça qu'on voit beaucoup de
notre homme parce qu'ils s'impliquent
qui disait moi ça va être tel candidat
je vais l'appuyer mais je vais tout
faire pour que l'autre candidate du même
parti donc 2 républicain exemple mais
l'autre passe pourquoi et l'est vous
allez voir tout est dans tout on va
revenir un peu par ricochet au 6 janvier
à l'insurrection ce qu'on dit de l'
appuyer quand je disais qu'il y avait
une élection frauduleuse et que c'est
moi qui est le véritable président et
que j'aurais dû gagner donc lui ça va
être mon candidat mais l'autre qui dit
non l'élection était correct bien c'est
bien plate mais c'est joe biden qu'il
gagne mais lui je vais pratiquement le
détruire en public pour pas qu'ils
soient le les temps 10 ans qui va
représenter mon parti donc son pouvoir
est là parce qu'il réussit jusqu'à un
certain point choisir par son influence
et parce que serait ce qu'un ancien
président des états unis dont ils
parlent les gens vont écouter qui veut
représenter le parti politique à
l'élection en novembre et ça marche pas
à tous les coups mais dans beaucoup dans
plus de 6 le washington post a fait une
enquête je pensais cette semaine dans
plus de 100 pour plus de 100
candidatures ça fonctionne cette formule
je demande de dire à lui parce que j'ai
été fidèle mais je vais lui donner mon
appui puis je vais un peu contrôlée à
lorgner le y est présent il laisse
toujours planer le doute qui va se
représenter en 2020 cas maintenant puis
veut revenir et 10 pour sa troisième
victoire
80 ben il va pas y approche les 80 j'ai
été un petit peu plus jeune que joe
biden qui lui va voir début 80 ainsi
recommandé en
tout plus de soixante dix ans plus de 75
ans donc c'est pas mais quand même je
pense que pour redonner à dos n'entrons
pas ce que je peux lui redonner
l'énergie est pas la même qu'à dubaï nom
qui est beaucoup moins en forme de son
envoi était ce qu'on peut percevoir et
qui encore je pense cette énergie là et
il l'a dit didier si tu fais pas de
sport celui plus longtemps
il y avait deux serveurs jack avait un
nombre finale d'énergie dans ta vie je
fais chaque fois que tant dépensé sa
enlevés at-on nombre final à oasis fais
pas de sport je garde tout en ondes
d'nrj complète
c'est quelqu'un prêt mais il prend
beaucoup pesé salik la liqueur ses skis
et ski prenaient le et les burgers fait
que c'est peut-être là la question de la
longévité contre je sais ballons propres
et essayer saint geours mai mais c'est
ça mais donald trump qui va moi mon avis
si j'avais une prévision à faire je veux
jamais faire une prévision flics sont
mais je pense qu'il va être là jusqu'à
presque la toute fin parce que s'ils
décident de postes présenté pour
expliquer qu raison parce qu'encore trop
de scandales ça va ça me troue
monopoliser un peu l'attention ben il
faut être là jusqu'à au maximum qu'il
peut pour contrôler qui va être le
candidat ou savez de quoi l'agenda
politique du parti républicain ça va
être quoi les sujets qui sont importants
c'est qu'est ce que les électeurs ils
vont se faire dire jour après jour qui
est important la vente c'est
l'immigration
après ça les bons c'est l'économie on
peut comprendre un petit peu plus
pourquoi et où la pandémie qui était
maintenant dans les discussions
l'avortement cesser toutes des choses
qui peut décider ça va être quoi le tank
de temps tu sais quoi qui va être
important quand il voit dans un rallye
politique en cas précis les gens s'ils
veulent gagner qui sont pas dans notre
hub vont se greffer un peu à ces sujets
à ce que lui veut dire qui est important
donc il garde un contrôle et c'est ce
qui fait en ce moment jusqu'à laisser
planer l'idée qui veut revenir en 2024
mais il veut décourager d'autres
personnes de se présenter mais arnaud
son mât qui vont le faire c'est à mon
avis sera pas seul à la prochaine
élection parce qu'il ya tellement de
controverses qu'elle a en tête un
avantage qui avait pas il ya quatre ans
où il ya trois ans des contrats verre
fld hantise ici c'est un peu parce que
trop de controverses les bleus quatre
ans on se disait en fait l'accès
présenté pour la première fois on disait
impossible avec près de 13 ans
priscilla taux impossibles qui est qui
qui gagne est impossible qu'ils
apprennent on en parlait avec
les gagnants étaient venus juste avant
les élections le disais nous on pensait
que
graber de possibles déterminer tout le
monde est sorti sur l'élastique
s'appelle dans
ma carrière je laisserai aux peaux et
l'usc
[Rires]
a osé prononcer comme
engager de l'argent gelé gaget passerait
à près de pau sims entre
ces communes et de l'autre les copines
tant d'autres qui repousse la menace à
ce congrès car en fait chaque
controverse nourrit encore plus haut de
la page parce que plus on en a
plus on en parle plus à dormir je la
prends jamais
l'école de mettre une photo
bref c'est sa piété juste avant tout si
tu disais à la blague mais pas la black
était dans le top 10 il donne du oui et
du matériel pour parler puis j'ai
l'impression que c'est aussi ce qui fait
ça ce qui fait la popularité ce qui on
en parle tellement puis certainement pas
de bon sens qui fait qu'ils y passer de
de candy de
jack à on en parle tellement qu'il dit
comme devenu on a créé un vrai qu'il a
été créé par les médias miklos au lycée
si on a trouvé une faute et je mets des
guillemets relançant scanner que son
mari soit dans leur langue et là c'est
les médias c'est paul effect news qui
avait pour effet de nous mêler les
russes le titre faisait d'aider les
forces nouvelles c'est sa défaite news
sur les réseaux sociaux ton se rappeler
qu'ils disaient qu hillary clinton était
dans un réseau de prostitution juvénile
ou pratiquement la taille et ce pas
seulement qui a été qu'ils étaient les
faits mais monsieur une ingérence russe
dans l'élection world
j'avais fait beaucoup de recherches
là-dessus physx et les médias en parler
tellement plus que les autres candidats
il parlait tellement des six scandale
quotidiennement dans les unes de
journaux sur twitter del icio stéphane
gaubert et lui parlait de après jour le
jour il dicte sd quoi l'actualité le
nombre de fois où sont tous et où sa
déclaration choc c'était le petit
bandeau à cnn tu es tout le temps donc
c'est leur créature c'est grâce à lui
que j'ai eue c'était cette vie cette
visibilité là on pense à le discréditer
il décrédibilise où il a donné de la
force à chaque fois c'est sa petite est
une business les médias aux états unis
donc qu'est ce qui est payant ce genre
de truc là donc c'est certain qui at il
dit est guetté par les phrases et dans
l'autre un petit fait un reportage sur
sept jours sur leur grade dmb lot et ça
va aller le chercher de l'auditoire que
tu t'étais des histoires en plus cette
histoire d' allégations d'agression
sexuelle d'harcèlement et qui était avec
une actrice porno at il ajouté un
candidat prêt ce qui les évangélistes
derrière lui que des gens hyper
religieux mais pourquoi parce que
justement il leur promettait qu'ils
allaient mettre fin un exemple au droit
à l'avortement infecté il était toujours
têtu voix qui est certain de valeur
c'est varié avant tu dis ok c'est le
même enfer tantôt la petite ferme les
yeux sur certaines choses parce que ça
fait ton enfant ex une créature des
médias oui là on en parle encore mais
j'ai l'impression qu'ils ont ce qu'ils
ont réalisé les médias aussi que dans le
gers il fallait qu'on compte en perd un
petit peu plus parce qu'ils se disent
qu'elle est toujours de
sérieux parce qu'au début c'est
tellement une blague quand on a parlé
des luttes internes avec 500 pensé que
ça serait un jour le président des états
unis avait la première femme peut-être à
briser le plafond de verre a relaté de
dire qu'ils allaient se présenter ce que
c'était la candidate idéale de choix
clair non je pense que pas mal de
membres s'entend là-dessus mais quand
même c'est entre les deux cci ont décidé
d'attirer de m attention sur 30
et j'ai hâte de voir qui va être conduit
par son au delà des démocrates même si
les républicains en ce moment de son
ancien vice président qui met la table
pour se présenter le rayon était sur le
même ticket présidentiel bon sens tant
qu'il faille y mener à la mort
invité au manoir est très divertissant
mais aussi le gouverneur de la floride
rendez säntis qui lui arrête pas
controverse après controverse de faire
parler de lui parce qu'il y compris que
la formule 3 c'est justement de faire
parler de toi tu es tout le don de ses
gains fbl donc la loi où tu peux plus
parler d'homosexualité l'identité de
genre et dans les écoles primaires tous
ça vient de lui et de l'espèce de kenzo
déjeuner parce que désolé c'est me
contre eux donc il fait parler du bannir
des livres dans les écoles c'est il va
tellement loin qui fait parler lui
pourquoi parce que lui aussi est
peut-être candidat potentiel en 2020 il
crée un style de
detroit pistons mais là c'est ça va
devenir presque une discipline politique
à mon avis les tcc quelques jeux au
dessus des potentiels candidats
républicains pour combler médecin
maintenant pour nous le desjardins peu
gauchiste québec par le gauchiste
québécois non parce que ce serait
considéré comme communiste c'était
vraiment chaud
non mais la
bohème et démocrates sont adroitement
oui
je me rappelle il y
avait des similitudes ses fans où le
conservatisme et où est ce que c'est ça
ta au
québec est vu comme un espèce de
communistes raté quelque chose c'est un
terme à 6 juin
à cuba
si quelqu'un qui est pomme est en cours
là pour la thérapie de conversion le
team et on le passe que mike pence il
ouvertement pour la théorie de tomber
c'est sa thérapie oui je sais qu'ils
sont tombés il y en a qui le sont pas il
y en a qui sont des conservateurs je te
dirai économistes sont pas des
conservateurs nécessairement sociale
parce que tu peux être où l'on saisit là
encore que c'est plate que te pas de
choix parce qu'on est con son
conservateur économique mais qu'ils sont
par exemple pour interdire l'avortement
et pour un bon l'émoi sexuelle et viol
son populaire d'un républicaine
conservatrice et conservateurs
économique
mais qui sont populaires y en a qui sont
et ce qu'ils sont assez populaire
pourquoi se rendre là parce que c'est
tellement étouffé par les gens qui
pensent comme tout homme qui essayait
des minoritaires par scanner le thé les
femmes que je te parlais tantôt millions
d'aidés qui vont se présenter du tout le
mettait aussi à la dernière élection
pour l'élection de 2020 il y avait dans
notre homme et il y avait du monde
contre lui c'est juste qu'ils n'ont
jamais réussi à rien gagné dans le
primaire respectives mais tu avais des
anciens conservateurs y en a 1 entre
autres joe walsh je me trompe pas que
lui il y avait son émission de radio
conservatrice qui était quand même bon
quelqu'un d'assez connu et qui en ce
moment est en train de travailler avec
des victimes de la tuerie de parcs line
en floride des jeunes du secondaire
lequel va organiser les manifestations
pour un meilleur contrôle des armes à
feu lui c'est un candidat républicain
qui est en train de discuter avec eux
pour faire une espèce de lobby pour
trouver un juste milieu que légiférer en
matière d'armes à feu fax est un exemple
qu'on eu par le passé de quelqu'un qui y
consacrent attend que les valeurs
conservatrices mais qui qui ce dimanche
de jugement aussi je vais aller chercher
des choses qui sont bonnes un peu à
gauche mais beau au centre existe un
autre exemple est par exemple p tit
crise christique et qui était un ancien
collègue de john dans son administration
ancien gouvernant d'une choisi mais qui
est un peu une farce et qui est
déprimante en plein scandale
ou jazzy ou est il y avait bloqué par
exemple par pont pourrait faire suer
l'autre personne ce qui est que josé
éthiquement parlant des pots en n'est
pas gagnant c'est la même chose et
l'autre question que je me pose je me
pose une question qui va être le chez
les démocrates mais ces gens là moi je
vois pas une liste est très long très
intéressante où il dit que va se
représenter n'y a pas le choix de le
dire parce qu était le président en
poste je peux pas dire non non je vais
pas faire d'autres membres fait qu'elle
lui ait dit oui je veux être candidat
mais c'est ce que j'avais à cacher de
l'argent même chose qui est en touche je
pense pas qu'il ait
trouvé quelqu'un qui est que les gens
disent mont houy problème honnêtement il
existe un bug dont kate walsh oui c'est
ça que ça c'est la base je pense pas que
ces cinq années qui vont se moquer de
soi parce qu'il est bon si on leur
valeur peut-être pas la bonne place mais
je de l'eau titiller quand même manque
une énergie un certain niveau les gens
sont pas satisfait de son bilan jusqu'à
maintenant le thé hip hop aux plages les
démocrates mais me ya pas livré la
marchandise comme il l'avait promis
kamala harris qui est l espèce de mon
dieu étoile montante qu'on se disait
elle est avec vice-présidente savait et
elle approche la base de la plante verte
j'étais est en arrêt toujours en arrière
de joe biden à l'est des dossiers des
dossiers soit controversé comme l
amélioration et l'immigration illégale
et ou autre mais on la voit pas tant que
ça c'est après cette et les gens sont
encore un peu à eux c est vouloir avoir
une michelle obama qui va aller en
politique à l'éthique après jamais ce
débat ce que les gens s'ennuient de
l'ère obama qui était tellement
pour être pour le thé que les armes de
trois ans après michael mann
personnalités publiques pour prendre
cette place là c'est une possibilité
theillaud pro à un moment donné je me
rappelle il veut dire humain qu'à
l'esprit anti métis et les états unis en
fait que le rappelez vous il ya le côté
les gens
oui comment l'oublier je sais que
j'avais la terre c'est qu'ils sont aussi
présents riz etc selon rentre plus dans
le côté loufoque les le feu de la chose
au début
mais les démocrates
il va falloir qu'ils fassent un calcul
politique parce que ben laden qui était
pas moi je suis à lille j'ai suivi les
primaires démocrates beaucoup de talent
en californie et à l'onu un monsieur est
allé voir les jeux les vauréens
rassemblement bernie sanders de dubaï
d'une d'autres y avait pas d'engouement
management le ciel et dernier choix tout
le monde dubaï dont je parlais je
faisais des vox pop avec le monde me dit
ah mais moi mon premier choix ce terme
est ton ennemi kobe chuck s'était
présenté à bernie sanders den team en
main une liste le canari ce blabla je
t'avais joe banner dernier puis à la fin
de l'élection il voter pour lui pourquoi
parce que toutes les autres avalanches
et c'était comme le pids et c'est le
seul qui va pouvoir les battre hommes
parce qu ils pas trop à gauche qui
frappent pas peur aux plus vieux
conservateurs étudie justement ce tango
c'est pas un jeune fax et y est âgé tout
ça va fonctionner y allèrent quelqu'un
quand même par l'abbé ticket qui est
habitué de dédit avec les gens de
l'autre côté de la ligne politique
fiction aller chercher mais y ait jamais
eu cette passion le bus est fier qu'on
avait à barack obama fac si c'est ça je
pense qu'ils doivent avoir parce que les
démocrates votre - les démocrates vont
au moins se présenter et démocrates vont
est un peu et bien qu'ils avaient déjà
fait le parallèle avec le jeu je peux m
me fait avancer les rushs mapaq le parti
québécois que beaucoup de petites
querelles internes c'est contre ma part
de justement se lancer un peu des roches
entre nous pour pouvoir faire avancer
certains vidéo parce que c'est un parti
de débat c'est qu'il va pas tandis que
les républicains sont un peu comme une
famille que même s'ils ont des chicanes
ainsi un leader qui est là qui a été
nommé mais on veut plus ferme et puis on
va juste le suivre sion cette fidélité
là avec la personne qui est en haut que
les démocrates ont pas qu'ils vont plus
débattent et d alexandrie au casot
cortese pour la renommer parce qu'ils
celle qui est la plus connue chez
résiste alors aucun problème à aller
prendre ni à avoir un micro devant être
mis à part les comptes joe biden si elle
a parlé contre lui elle va pas à vos
posters à ce que ces sons son président
de son parti
pour ça que c'est difficile deux dit
qu'ils vont aller chercher une
personnalité publique une substance et
qu'il faudrait qu'elle est vraiment de
la substance parce qu'il y en ont eu le
parlement estime qu'elles sont capables
d'écrire d'engouement puis un mouvement
puis fièvre comme tu dis c'est pas
justement aux caisses de carter elle
pourrait se présenter ça sera la
première élection parce que tu dois
avoir 35 ans pour te présenter dans la
constitution peut quand même et tu dois
être bon citoyen américain être neo
est remis aux états unis ou sinon années
de parents mirc ailleurs puis avoir
vraiment citoyenneté et du soir 35 ans
donc elle veut pas se présenter avant
mais est tellement considère à gauche
pied terrain à imane ici leur petite
anecdote quand je parle alexandre et aux
cadeaux cartes assez les moments je
reçois de plus deux courriers l'un
tellement les gens la déteste en fait
c'est soit tu l'as d'or ou swatch
l'adetem incident sans séquelles
mais différemment mais il y aussi ces
espèces de
2,2 capacité de créer un engouement est
de mobiliser du monde intensément qui
sait peut-être une façon de combattre le
feu par le feu c'est ça et scaling
alexandre et aux cases de côté en se
mettant avec quelqu'un qui est plus
modérée parce que toujours marqué à
l'oti vice président
donc ça pourrait être une des
possibilités parce que pour moi c'est un
bon niveau de ses idées mais juste au
niveau de la façon qu'elle s'exprime
quelque capable d'aller chercher des
jeunes qui est capable d'aller chercher
des gens des minorités jeunes filles qui
travaillent dans les bords est restée
parents viennent de porto rico a vient
du bronx il ya comme une histoire
derrière du rêve américain mais qui va
chercher qu'il va chercher des électeurs
en fait pour moi russe à s'exprime bien
capable de justement parler un langage
jeune un peu d'être sur les réseaux
sociaux une allée chercher ces gens là
qui votent pas donc pour moi avec cocher
beaucoup de cases mais ces idées sont
considérés trop à l'extrême pour aller
chercher des indépendants et des
républicains modérés fait vraiment tanné
semaine de trek de candidat républicain
pour qu'elle apparaisse comme ceux
facilement c'est si je comprends bien
dans le tome i extrême aussi pour ça que
je dis pas que ça va pas arriver parce
que dans mon tour nous a appris que tout
ton possible mais je pense pas que ça va
t elle nécessairement il ya beaucoup de
gens qui souhaiteraient ça c'est boris
enders est quand même passé proche c'est
le même genre d'idée ont beaucoup plus
vieux mais c'est un homme qui est là
depuis longtemps qui je veux je peux
mettre tout le monde en même pas nîmes
élire une femme aussi c'est comme indice
est déjà élire un afro américain on
était on était vraiment ailleurs élire
une femme va falloir qu'ils aient rempli
certaines cases qu'elles soient pas trop
si trop ce et hillary clinton était trop
des fois masculine commun qu'elles
s'habillent et puis comment parler tu es
trop froid dans ses émotions ccsa il
s'est encore vraiment difficile piano
des étoiles montant mais est ce qu'ils
vont être encore vingt candidats à
s'auto et
on va voir son nom jusqu'à 2024 qui est
des gens qui peuvent ressortir justement
qu'il y ait des tragédies ou autre ou
des événements tu étais toujours des
gens qui rise above puis qu'ils peuvent
à des candidats intéressants donc on a
quand même le temps de voir venir pataky
que m puis au sein du parti républicain
est ce que dans leur job pas encore un
appui des deux élus p-dg de walk été le
théâtre maya les commissions dans lequel
jamais trop tôt au capitole les pieds
des gens très bien qui est qui disent
non et l'inde janvier prochain perdu
contact avec la réalité in fact ayez
aussi se dire aux autres y aussi des
opposants mais c'est une minorité a
vaincu et ces gens là s'ils parlent mais
ils seront tous ils sont en ce moment
des campagnes de millions de dollars
pour que les chenilles qui est il ya
deux en fait il ya deux républicains sur
la commission en ce moment seulement
puis ils sont détestés de l'ordre parti
de la cfm même éjecté de son poste
qu'elle avait de numéro 3 de son parti
en dînant en tête une traite parce
qu'ils étaient dégustés de faire ça
tandis que l comme je disais tantôt
civile dans ma tête je me dis une vraie
de vraie république m et alors que tout
les cas ce que c'est drôle de voir tous
les progressistes les démocrates qui la
voient comme l'espèce de sauveur mais
quand finalement et contre l'avortement
un compte à peu près d'une mosquée dans
leur valeur baisser jusque là dans ce ce
point-là acer quelque chose parce que
dans l'autre un bon c'est son ennemi
politique mais non il y en a beaucoup
qui après l'élection est pas prêt de
l'ex entre l'insurrection qui sont
sorties qui ont critiqué même tête
rousse qui est en tête des candidats que
les gens connaissent le nom le quittant
sénateurs est exact qui s'est présenté
comme candidat à la présidence qui est
dit que c'était du terrorisme ce qui
s'était passé d'un autre leader et de
l'avenir du sénat mitch mcconnell qui a
dit non ça peu de bon sens dont une
bonne part de responsabilité il y en a
plein comme cela l'est et elles ont fait
que la question n'avait fait le podcast
et quelques mois ça serait différent et
ces gens là après son tout changer parce
qu'ils ont vu le contrôle qu'avec trump
your pas moi c'est ma seule explication
ici on le par pour leur peau dans le
sens et pour la prochaine élection il se
faisait crier après dans les aéroports
parce que c'était des traites les
tigistes parce qu'ils avaient parlé
contre lui tous les gens qui le suivent
le c'est comme une naissance je passais
une siècle mais sont ils voient juste
d'un autre homme comme quelqu'un de
presqu'un être parfait qui peut faire
n'importe quoi et j'ai donc un peu
commenté il récemment êtes vous encore
pour tel leader guépard les cours de
vous après après l'insurrection bla bla
bla qui est dit j'ai vu la lumière
il ya vu la lumière donc il y compris
qu'ils avaient eu tort et le maintenant
c'est comme ses collègues qui était à
mes côtés et puis on va aller de l'avant
semble acquiescer contrôle sur son parti
qui est très grand et je me rappelle pas
qu'ils aient que j'aimerais bien citer
mais quand on va partir eux ils vont
avoir ce encore ce bagage là des femmes
dans le futur ce qu'un jour dans notre
jeu ne sera plus là les élus leur vont
avoir à défendre de l'avoir protégé dans
tellement de dossiers que tu dis là
c'est un autre prison c'est le démocrate
qui avait fait
la bougie d'allumage de l'insurrection
l'a jamais qu'elle ré qu'elle aurait pu
se rendre jusque là alors aidez même son
propre parti lui aurait dit tiens c'est
la porte qui va en pressant destitution
tu es mieux de démissionner avant parce
que sinon tu vas te faire démissionner
et c'est pas ce qu'on voit là je n'ai
pas du tout ce qu'on voit avec ses
quelque chose un peu de jamais vu nixon
ont fait beaucoup de parallèles onexone
scandale du watergate qui touche quand
même des élections mais un moment donné
il ya un sénateur qui frappent à sa
porte pied du games et la femme ne va
plus avoir notre appui acte est mieux de
démissionner parce qu'ils se montrent
femme encore ça va être pire pour toi
parce que notre parti va pas être
derrière toi et ça il n'y a pas de gens
qui l'ont fait c'est dans un univers
parallèle s'il l'avait fait bon
peut-être que dans mon champ paraître
démissionner et mike spencer était
président des états unis ce qui est pas
nécessairement de choses grisons les
gens qui sont plus démocrates dans leur
façon de penser
fait que le pilot il ya justement une
commission d' enquête sur ces événements
le loto du capital
c'est quoi ça peut mener à quoi ceci m
et l'autre dans le fond on aurait appris
que deux matches étaient au courant qu
est-ce qu avant c était pas facturés qui
dit que les élections étaient ils
étaient truquées il y avait la bonne
information comme pitau monde autour de
lui disait n'ont ils rien qui peut il
est en panne d'essence d'accord ça pue
ou six classes au capitole mais il
faisait partie de l'orchestration tout
se met le son des morceaux ça que ça
fait marie pense quand
il vote en prison
c'est comme
à la guerre en ukraine ces genres aulas
poutine va être accusé de crime c'est
quand moi mais signalé par un juge
pierre j'imagine valley en prison
c'est ça c'est qu'est ce qui peut se
passer était honnêtement la réponse
plate cyril va avoir un rapport
c'est sophie
il va avoir un rapport avant les
élections de mi mandat ce qui est
toujours un calcul politique dans tout
parce que ils les démocrates veulent
propre profiter justement tout ça puis
il ya quand même une bonne stratégie
avec ce qui se passe le problème c'est
ce que les gens ça va leur faire changer
d'idée parce qu'il ya quand même sa
fille ivanka trump qui disait croire le
procureur général les états unis qui me
disaient qu'ils avaient aucune preuve
sur que l'élection avait été volé 2 le
procureur général des états-unis nommé
par trois hommes qui est un espèce de
yes men le nommer parce qu'il était
vraiment le politiquement derrière dans
notre homme qui est dit que le président
était détaché de la réelle raison des
positions et saison de vie des extrêmes
ce c'est l'espèce de dre témoin vedette
jusqu'à maintenant
puis on a appris et dans les derniers
jours aussi qu' il était au courant que
c'est illégal si mike pence le
vice-président l'époque empêcher la
certification des résultats qui étaient
vraiment au coeur de l'insurrection la
raison de l'insurrection le site et pour
l'empêcher de certifier les résultats
qui donnaient la victoire à jubail c'est
leur dernière carte qu'ils pouvaient
jouer il n'y avait aucune base légale
aucune base constitutionnelle est ce
qu'on a démontré ce que d'entre eux
étaient au courant puis même si tu es
dans l'illégalité pistes abordées sur
absolument réunion quand même dit non on
veut tu vas 6 monter un tract pas
patriote est ce que ça a eu comme effet
c'est que les gens scandaient mike pence
devraient être pendus y était on ne
s'inquiétait à 40 pieds les groupes
d'extrême droite qui avait un plan pour
l'exécuter santschi cac 40 pieds du vice
président des états unis qui est en
théorie un allié dans notre champ et que
jamais il appelait pour voir comment
commence à les six étaient corrects sa
famille en sécurité et avec ses enfants
au congrès ton qui est jamais une
vérification alors tout ça c'est
démontrer le financement ces photos de
mme o'neill s'est vraiment être là qui
va avoir du peut avoir des accusations
par exemple de fraude si on réussit à
prouver certaines choses parce qu'une ou
un fonds de 200 x 30 millions de dollars
2 j'en passe qui leur disaient honte
après ce soir volé l'élection des nîmois
de l'argent pour notre défense devant
des tribunaux parce qu'on va aller
prouver qu'on ne gagne et que si vous
voulez le que ça soit moi votre
président de l'aimf d'argent et
finalement il est payé pour des frais
d'hôtel dans les hôtels trump pour sa
campagne pour rembourser les dettes
électorale c'est une infime partie qui a
été utilisé pour la locomotion millions
qui
ne retombe ici par contre sa défense et
que si tu les ript caractère de cette
façon l'aide sociale est dans mon camp
du club en banque
y a quand même été si c'est bien entrés
légalement mais par contre s'il sait
déjà que perdu puis que tout ceci s'est
basé sur absolument rien l'autre pas
avoir une des fraudes parce que tu peux
passer comme paringaux fanmi pour
quelqu'un qui a le cancer qu'il n'y a
jamais le cancer c'est légal de faire la
queue de demander de l'argent qu'ils le
fassent que tu veux avec après mais si
tu pars d'une prémisse que c'était pas
vrai était au courant que c'est pas vrai
l'oeil comme une notion peut-être de
fraude qui peut étaler qui peut être
chercher fax et c'est peut-être ce qui
va être qui va être dommageable le plus
pour le président il y aussi en
parallèle la commission denquête il ya
des gens qui veulent le poursuivre au
civil des policiers qui ont été battus
qui ont été traumatisés des gens aussi
qui était l'un des membres du congrès
qui qui a jamais vont avoir cette
journée là où leurs vies étaient
menacées qui veulent le poursuivre au
civil parce qu'on est fort sur la
poursuite aux etats unis c'est le pô le
pays d'abord souhaitant donc même si
j'ai pas de voie criminelle d'aller
chercher quand même une coupe 2 millions
sap est quelque chose qui est une
conséquence pour lui est ce qu'ils
peuvent l'empêcher en ce moment de se
représenter non est ce que le
département de la justice qu'ils soient
démocrates ou républicains veut vraiment
passer les menottes à un ancien
président américain ces techniques dans
des gect sur la planète le tata cote est
moins bonne qualité je voudrais qu'elle
mais je comprends et je dois mille cas
que les fissures lui fut peu importe qui
tu es normal map en normal nixon n'a pas
été arrêté puis avait des preuves c'est
vraiment qu'ils avaient commandés con
qu'on fasse un entrés par effraction
pour aller espionner un autre parti puis
on a choisi pour justement parce qu'il
avait démissionné pour que ce qui est
pas encore plus des divisions politiques
de pover d'accusation mettant criminelle
car en théorie tu avais tu avais les
éléments peau strauss kahn certaines
limites ja il pense avoir les éléments
tian georgy on a eu 1 ap londres la
villetelle petit nixon y avait les
fameux enregistrements même tuant même
avant la commission l'entendais dire
trouvez-moi des votes trouvez-moi des
votes pour gagner la georgie et j'ai
besoin de dix mille roses mais le vote
et ça n'a rien changé les une enquête en
ce moment georges i quit en parallèle
fac ya plein de petites enquêtes ici et
là il va avoir le fameux rapport qui est
une pression sur le département de la
justice que tu dis mais c'est arrête pas
dans le champ parce que tu as arrêté
rudy giuliani qui était son avocat
complètement qui s'est lui salaire qui
était sous la nuit de l'élection qui le
convaincu quand tout le monde dit no 2
pas gagné ne veut pas dire que tu as
gagné devant le public américain bien
dit non au togo n'y fait même si on
n'avait pas fini de compter les votes
l'italie en premier de la nuit ce les
gens adorent mais pas ce moment là j'en
faisais partie j'avais peur
tous et toutes ces journées là bas qu'on
a un résultat final qui est dit mais on
a gagné on devrait arrêter de compter
les votes parce que sinon on va te
coucher ashton
les élections
moi j'ai pas dormi pendant sa durée 5
jours avant qu on a le résultat la nuit
je me rappelle je regardais et et cnn ou
un autre explique je me disais ils vont
finir par le dire à petit
appelez ça se dit pas le cherche le
terme en france m étais quand on donne
telle et telle qu'elle président je me
dis que je peux pas pas être devant ma
télé le jour
fatidique
éprouvées comme son enquête c'est pas le
système de justice qui meurt on veut pas
que ses politiques il ya une enquête
criminelle dans le sens quel département
la justice arrêté aussi des centaines de
personnes des insurrections des membres
des profs boyz qui sont les membres de
l'extrême droit des autres qui peuvent
qu'être un autre groupe de l'extrême
droite des gens qui disent avoir été là
la demande du président e dans leur
défense des isbas en était lundi en même
temps je me mets dans leurs tacles et
qui croise les essais m'ont prise je
vais mettre dans la tête de quelqu'un
qui croit qu'elle président peu importe
ce qu'il dit est la vérité parce que
c'est lui qui est notre leader et ceux
qui disaient on est en train de
renverser la démo les démocrates sont en
train de vous voler votre élection sont
en train de renverser la démocratie ce
qu'ils font c'est pas correct et vous
êtes le dernier espoir c est à ne pas
être là-bas peut-être pas à prendre des
armes il ya des gens qui vont croire
qu'ils vont faire tout en leur pouvoir
pour empêcher cette certification de
l'élection les gens de l'extrême droite
qui veulent eux déjà pas avoir un job à
dénouer kamala harris encore moins parce
qu'il est à moitié afro américaine s'est
déjà lot havre paul c'est une femme fait
que ça t'incite à la rue dans leurs
dépositions 10 au départ tout en la
justice mais on le fait parce que notre
commandant en chef nous le demander à
qui font le lien et c'est très difficile
de cadets parole
directe avec we fonds d actions
département de la justice et des
enquêtes au civil tête des enquêtes dans
certains états aussi avec moi je pense
qu'il va avoir des arrestations
éventuellement peut-être johnny semaine
qui était son conseiller juridique lui
c'est lui qui fait toute cette histoire
là qui est donné à mag peine ce document
qui détient voir si la justification de
pourquoi tu m'en empêcher la
certification des résultats et n'importe
quel avocat ou quelqu'un connais un
petit peu la conscience de voyance a pas
de bon sens non non c'est ça qui va
faire
avec lui était comme un peu le
mastermind là dedans tout le monde
disait autour de lui dit s'éloigner de
cette personne ne t'as vu une autre
avocate kelly a pensé le quai systech et
castro puis le venezuela qui était
derrière cette île c'était pratiquement
une histoire l'acte 1 vous tue mais dans
un film dit voyant ça n'a aucun sens les
théories de conspiration si loin bien
d'aller dire ça quand même dans les
conférences de presse qui cite une de
ses conseillères juridiques avec tous
ces gens losc rubans voire vont payer un
peu pour le président c'est possible je
pense que pour certains ce serait une
certaine satisfaction de voir que au
moins des gens peuvent juste les
manifestants qui sont devenus des
métiers qui sont devenus des
insurrections liste mais qui a des gens
plus haut placé qui étaient eux dans le
bureau ovale à observer tous au biac as
gardé les bras croisés puisque au delà
tous que trump a bâti un site et pour
moi ce qu'est ce qui est fait de plus
grave en guinée c'est de rien faire
s'est il pas tweeté dias a pris des
heures avant qui tous épi qui envoie un
message je me souviens qu'ils s est
arrêtée respecter les autorités de
l'ordre mais je vous aime puis je
comprends que vous êtes fâché c'est pas
vraiment ce que quand un enfant mais tu
est ce correct ce que tu fais tu donnes
pas de taper ses doigts la tcc envisage
aussi lui je peux trouver ce qui était
sa valeur dans une tente pour garder sow
sur un écran puis il y avait de la
demande
pays y voyait qu'il y avait des
manifestants qui sont allés l'appui dans
les images qu'on a vu de la commission
d'enquêté un documentariste britannique
qui était avec les profs boys avec le
groupe d'extrême droite pour faire un
documentaire qui les suivait puis que
pendant le discours de bach dont deux
chambres 1une à distance un peu du
congrès du capitole mary marché des
jeunes en leur direction enfin qu'il y
avait déjà eu l'idée d'aller faire cette
entrée illégale au cabinet depuis de
renverser le résultat puis de faire je
ne sais trop quoi s'il s'y croiser nancy
pelosi un mike pence une alexandrie au
casot carte sd qui ai dit je pensais que
j'allais mourir lancé jeudi à 6 chez
l'ennemi numéro un des ces gens là
puissent y suivons faire autre chose
avant si les espèces à leurs idées
derrière sopi mike pence qui était
recroquevillé dans un coin avec la
sécurité et des élus qui étaient
pratiquement tous des tam qui finalement
ont vécu ce traumatisme up qui ont pas
le choix d'être derrière leur
ex-président s'ils veulent avoir une
carrière l'éthique après ça aussi ça dit
assez spécial t la petite et menacer sa
sécurité pierre
contraire on dirait comme godzilla au
king kong meetic avance plus la
référence du genre d affaire des bombes
qu'ils frappent des missiles qui frappe
plus l'effet russe comme continuer à
tranquillement avancé joe wright penn
enfants et on sait que rien qui pourrait
que
finir ce métier cet événement le sait
sur fifth avenue où il avait dit pendant
la campagne électorale pourrait tirer
sur quelqu'un que les gens votent oui
quand même pour moi c'est ce il y avait
raison on dirait qu'on continue qu'on
verrait ce je vais celui puis il ya du
monde qui ferait jarbawi joly il y avait
raison c'est fou le les images
l'insurrection que je me rappelle je
joue là je vois les les alertes je
regarde la télé je change de poste je
vois ce qui se passe l'été je vois les
washington que j'adore tes j'ai déjà
habitées j'aime les etats-unis + jeu
métier mais qu'est-ce que je chanterai
ne voit jamais et j'imagine reçoit dans
une démocratie comme celle là jamais
j'aurais pu imaginer devoir se un jour
dans ma vie honnêtement
c'était un choc pied est-ce que j'ai
jamais réussi à comprendre c'est comment
justifier quand et des conservateurs
américains que tu dises toujours bac de
boucé les policiers les forces de
l'ordre c'est qu'ils critiquaient
blacklight vendeurs pourquoi avoir
justement a été super et offensif avec
les policiers entier me retourne et le
ils font la même chose sur les images
tellement dit c'est la voie entre les
policiers qui demande à rennes et qui
perdent connaissance sur les images qui
se font et il y en a une les gens avec
des battes de baseball j'ai vu les
ballons d'or qui j'ai vu des poteaux le
qui tenaient les drapeaux il y en a qui
sont morts comme ça qui tu dis 'comment
est-ce qu'ils peuvent justifier qu'un
gros contraste il y en avait beaucoup de
vétérans il y avait il y avait des gens
qui étaient encore policiers ou pompiers
ou dans l'armée qui était dans les
insurrections et cela jusqu'à quel point
tu es rendu loin pourtant prendre aux
forces de l'ordre que tu dit défendre
dans tes valeurs les plus profondes
ça c'est quelque chose que j'ai de la
difficulté encore à ce jour à comprends
pas les gens qui ont été quand même
radicalisé puisqu'elle sont tombés dans
une loupe de fausses informations petit
répit
après ce que nous sommes soit est
directement castrés ce ou non je dis
bien peut créer ce climat le qui fait en
sorte que ce ça peut arriver une ainsi
de toujours remettre en question le
processus électoral puis juste les les
médias en général
si c'est lui qui écrit
parce que la cour suprême il y avait une
majorité de juges conservateurs mais
jusque avait nommé puis même là il
croyait il y avait six est basé sur rien
les fraudes électorales sait on jamais
voulu même regarder les dossiers s'il
n'y avait pas de ya pas de balle arras à
la cantine dit et qui étaient propres
juges cantonaux me dise non les juges un
peu partout aux états unis refusent
aussi de voir que la fraude ce que de
l'afro diamant toutes les élections dans
n'importe quelle démocratie tu es déjà
un mort qui ont voté ou une mauvaise
adresse ceux qui veulent deux fois on en
voit partout dans vos québec on envoie
au canada lorsqu'on disait les fraudes
par milliers des valises remplies des
véhicules remplis de vote fort et
c'était vraiment très loin le des
machines qui étaient frauduleuses pour
comptabiliser les votes on aller
beaucoup plus loin qu'une fraude qui ne
suis pas dire non mais n'importe quel
front n'est pas bonne mais combien ce
que je faisais kinky normal dans une
élection avec des millions de personnes
qui votent cela prend des choses et
quand tu dis
liminaire ce contexte là mais c'est vrai
parce que si dès le départ tu dis après
que tous les juges tandis qu'il y avait
pas de fondement qu'est les gens prêtent
toi ton ticket pas de fondement qui
était enfant et on dit à part peut-être
dans notre championnat que je pense que
lui croyait aussi à tous ceux que tu
continues de dire jusqu'à même la
journée de certification des résultats
que de gagner l'élection b dessus
j'alimente sociaux mois de décembre
avaient arrêté après que le processus
juridique avait suivi un peu son cours
il y en a qui disent tu es à la mi
décembre s'ils avaient dit bon moi je
pense que j'ai gagné c'est si je juge
l'intention des représentants de 1024
changer le système puis de prouver que
peu importe on n'aurait pas eu le même
résultat nécessairement s'est mêlé ya
jamais conseillé même aujourd'hui à ce
jour il n'est pas conseillé la victoire
est au juste l'image qu'ils atteignent
les états unis que l'ancien président et
paul à la cérémonie pour le nouveau
présente et tout ça c'était un peu un
mauvais film
on espère qu'ils répondent à un deuxième
mauvais film c'est ce que et les suites
sont jamais des passants
on dirait qu'on parle de technip puis
ça fait qu'on roule mais
demandant qu'on en parle
la paire place si c'est quoi c'est quoi
qui que toi qui t'attire cpi le sais que
tu trouves beaupuy pourquoi tilt et
pourquoi dessus il s'intéresse autant
mais il ya plein de choses que j'aime
qui le fixe et 50 payeurs les 50 états
sont tellement différents tubes en
californie tu vas new york ben ça c'est
le type et qu'on va aller peut-être les
québécois en floride mais les gens sont
différents il est tellement bon monde
aux etats-unis aussi la culture au site
et je dirais une culture qui pète
latino-américaine qui croisait avec une
culture américaine au niveau de la
musique du cinéma et il ya quand même
quelque chose d'extraordinaire un peu
partout puis je dire je suis allé au
texas qui arrivaient les manifestations
compte conclut contre les lois contre
l'avortement j'essaie de le formuler
mieux je rencontre du monde aussi qui
tellement enrichissant qui quittent
apporte quelque chose aussi parce qu'une
vision différente si pas tous des gens
qu'on peut mettre dans une même boîte
c'est ce que je trouve que la beauté des
états unis s'ils disent toujours c'est
le l'endroit où tu peux rêver faire des
découvertes de chercheurs l'expression
le lundi 20 juin ça va me revenir
à l'endroit des opportunités tout ça
donc il ya du beau aux états unis et les
paysages les parcs nationaux dès jeudi
géographiquement parlant j'ai toujours
aimé ça la politique la façon que ces
faits quand c'est bien fait ce contre
pouvoir laquelle toc c'est pas le
premier ministre ou de président que
tout le pouvoir qu'ils étaient des élus
qui peuvent des ben non c'est président
votre au loin nous on va lui dire tu
sais quoi la bonne chose à faire il ya
tellement de choses intéressantes
moi je suis allé ce qui a été même mon
élément je traite déclencheur pour
vraiment me spécialiser là dedans après
mon bac comme à l'oral à s'entendre ça
j'allais travailler six mois à
washington à l'université la défense
américaine mais j'étais là en 2009 tu
arrivé trois jours après
l'assermentation de barack obama
donc tu es dans une espèce de nouvelle
ère du tout était possible si les gens
sortaient d'une bombe début de la guerre
en irak la guerre en afghanistan c'était
la fin d'une certaine économique qui
avait tout cette espèce de renouveau
très espoir est très tout est rose dans
l'avenir de dire qu'un président froid
me requinque il y avait il y avait une
espèce d'homme aux états unis que
j'avais pas vu nécessairement envie d'y
vivre c'est j'ai vraiment appris à aimer
sont encore plus et encore à ce jour six
commun c'est comme un mariage si c'est
pour le meilleur et pour le pays un
moment tout les clichés je pourrais
l'aider quand je pense aux états unis ça
m'empêchera pas d'y aller est ce que
j'aime moins ce que j'aime et oui ces
ménages baigne là-dedans tous les jours
que c'est pas juste avec un regard de
deux touristes ou des personnes qui
apprécient les états unis je trouve ce
dimanche que je vois je reconnais pas le
pays que gm j'ai des amis américains
aiment beaucoup qui reconnaissent pas ça
aussi qui ont vu tellement de division
avec la pandémie qui sont même pas au
même niveau qu'on a eues ici qu'on sent
qu'on sort divisé épuisé de ce qui s'est
passé c'était autre chose là bas c'est
le convoi le pire aussi au niveau du
système de santé ce qui est encore très
difficile
donc ce côté là il faut jamais me
freiner de m'y intéresser m'étais je te
dirais que c'est plus la relation plus
difficile note entre nous deux entre les
états-unis - le teaser de vie podcast ci
que l'espèce de l'image des états unis
comme un genre d'exemples de liberté
puis deux des pays modernes dont on
s'inspire t du les unes par sept au rôle
qui est prélevé de seppi
qu'est-ce que ça prendrait pour que pour
que cette paix ils retrouvent un
semblant d'unité par un semblant c'est
quelque chose qui est possible ou ce pas
quelque chose que tu vois je vais
répondre à ta deuxième partie parce que
je les sais pas c'est quoi la la formule
c'est la formule a traité des trucs
clichés de ces écoutes et d'être capable
de voir le point de vue de l'autre a dit
que ça peut m'arriver
1c sapinettes mangent pendant une phase
d'espoir que ça va s'améliorer est-ce
qui va avoir un jour parce que joe biden
a fait sa campagne en disant qu'avec le
rassembleur qui allait tendre la main
aux républicains démocrates et le frein
certain niveau mais il peut pas
réconcilier ce pays qui est tellement
divisée est-ce que ça va dans quelques
années que ça va arriver peut-être mail
en ce moment c'est les gens s'inquiètent
même pour la démocratie américaine c est
ce que il y en a qui vont dire qu'en
2020 c'est les dernières élections
démocratiques mois qui vont connaître
les états unis il y en aura pas d'autre
sens qu'en ce moment il mettre tellement
de gens qui vont contrôler un peu le
résultat d'élections des gens qui
politiquement sont nommés là pour
décider quel bulletin de vote devant une
borne pas factice l'avenir et port aux
eaux contrat je te dirai qui est encore
plus encore plus noir qu'il était ya
quelques années et baisse de confiance à
voir les médias se chercher ton
information ou de plus en plus il est
seul on veut plus les médias
traditionnels fois qu'on se tourne vers
les musiques sont plus extrêmes à gauche
ou à droite avec ça ça aide pas et
foncez au plus bas la confiance dans les
médias que ça a été dans au début des
années 2000 c'était quand même mieux que
c'est aujourd'hui une fois qu'était
cette idée de fake new skies fais ce
qu'on me demande qui fait son bout de
chemin où tout peut être fait news
n'importe quoi sous le soleil ce que je
vois de soleil ces gens qui dansent pas
s'appuyer les bleus annonce pas ça c'est
fait nous on sait ce contresens et à la
réalité avec ou des fêtes de prendre
l'information ils les seuls y en a qui
disent reste l espoir en 10 mai d'une
espèce d'unité qui je souhaite je veux
vraiment que ça soit là je souhaite pas
ça mais si ce temps en septembre celle
qui avait lu une taie après je sais
c'est dans la tragédie qui vont se
réunir mais je souhaite pas du tout
tragédie fake c'est pour ça que je dis
que d'un côté ou de l'autre c'est
difficile mais après le 11 septembre
jamais le patriotisme été aussi haut ce
même site george bush était pas aimer un
démocrate il ya personne qui allait par
les conflits ou des parle tout le monde
était derrière le président qui était le
commandant chez font de temps en temps
de crise il fallait derrière lui c'était
lui qui est important de suivre c'est
tout ce que ça dure juste un peu et si
la pandémie certaines crises on sait peu
plus au sérieux on l'a vu comme un même
ici l'été on se ressert pendant six mois
puis après ce ont
aussi pillé les états unis sont connus
pour peuvent avoir une pensée collective
pour ce que le communiste ça leur fait
si palestine pensée très individualiste
faisant côté un petit peu philosophique
de la chose en ce sens que c'est leur
liberté individuelle c'est pas la
liberté collective transition on a une
espèce de façon générale de lentilles et
collectives quand je regarde la société
dit je pense à mon prochain aussi je
pense pas que ça moi tu es je me dis et
les sous que je donne à mes impôts mais
ça va d'autres personnes qui sont dans
le besoin tandis que là bas sinon c'est
l'égalité des chances eh ben c'est pas
mon problème qui atténue en situation
défavorisée arrange toi on ne peut pas
de donner de l'argent pour te sortir de
la misère on n'a pas donné de l'argent
parce que moi j'ai réussi puis manger la
grosse bmpg la job parce que j'ai bûché
que j'ai travaillé fort mais c'est l
afro américains qui avaient pas d'accès
à l'immobilier ou à rien pas mal toute
ta vie par par des politiques qui
étaient parentes et défavorisées toute
ta vie plutôt pas des d'après santé pts
et l'université ça coûte à peu près 200
milles de draft est faite il ya vraiment
eu une vision très
très basique de ski l'égalité une ans en
ski je veux des 1500 pièces à tout le
monde c'est l'égalité y mettiez
cc66 possède pas ce qui s'est passé
c'est pas salé qui jusque une naissance
qui est la personne qui n'y avait que
rien verser les personnes qui né avec un
million à son compte ça sent bien c'est
la même chose non c'est ça c'est mais
c'est la base de rêve américain de dire
qu'elle peut venir de n'importe où ou
pis mais dans les faits ça dépend dans
quel état tu es né dans quel contexte
est née elle c'était dans un état du sud
ta couleur de peau et pas blanche met
déjà l'eau du port avec sa part avec une
longueur d'avancé son histoire avec même
si on est en 2022 puisque tu dis que ça
change et ce quand même ça la réalité ni
une femme dans certains endroits et il y
en a plein le jeu des bretons
orientation sexuelle ton genre tsahal
encore un effet qui est vraiment
important donc pour eux l'individualisme
a tout le temps restait généralistes ont
semblé des gens qui sont pas comme cela
mais il ya quand même cette notion dans
les valeurs fondatrices oui c'est ça de
dire qu' on est capable justement
d'avoir une cette égalité des chances et
je te demande tu peux avoir ton âme tu
fais ce que tu veux mais tu peux pas
décider ce que tu veux avec ton corps
c'est une femme sous sol en thèse là
dessus mais c'est ce qui est un peu
ridicule la liberté s'arrête à un
certain endroit mais paient pas pour
tout le monde n'est pas égal c'est ce
qui est byden d'inondations disco qui
est fait jamais après les tueries d' de
poser oui on veut vivre dans un pays où
la liberté est une des valeurs principal
mais à m'amener il faut aussi
réglementer pour avoir un minimum est où
ta liberté la limite atteinte
à la liberté individuelle la liberté
collective à un moment donné ça va
ensemble c'est ta liberté individuelle
se connecte toi tu es responsable ça
revient la force contre des tentes aux
responsabilités en mai de façon
collective c est ce qu il faut que je
fasse quelque chose pour pour les autres
le petit peu juste pour toi que ton
petit besoins individuels des gens qui
abusent ceux qui disaient qu'il y ait
des gens qui abusent de cette liberté là
puis on ne peut au choix des vins des
balises mme mais il va lui et quoi en
fait pas
merci vraiment je vois ce qu'on peut
entendre parler politique américaine et
c'est le temps de weeds de famille plug
est belle elle est la saison des mordus
de politique est terminée mais ça
revient en septembre dans quelle mesure
êtes d'annoncer que je vais de retour
aussi avancé péter cardillo
98,5 avec patrick lagacé mais je vais te
le à peu près tout l'été est ce nom à
nouveau aussi où j'écris et je suis un
homme monde c'est pas mal sysmans
surtout et
élection je commence à être pompé sur
instagram parce que j'y arrive juste à
temps car l'application va mourir oui
mes spectacles je suis mais je vais pas
faire tes cheveux quand même une
millenium et
je reste dans mon
twitter c'est vraiment une extension moi
même parfois léger c'est des fois dans
la rétine de moudéry parce que c'est une
belle plateforme que j'aime beaucoup
faire si les gens veulent ils suivent un
peu ce que je fais je dirais que c'est
twitter instagram à qui sont elles qui
sont vraiment les voir facebook touche
moyens
comme une bonne mine
merci beaucoup
de déconvenues excellente offre tout un
podcast combien
oui
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre aller
sur le titre i entre le pitch vous
abonner pour trop dollars par mois c'est
trop de longs mois et trois pièces par
mois hors glace par mois et vous avez
les pas de carte en avance acquise avec
les premiers de votre groupe d'amis
avoir quitté les podcasts qu'ils
allaient avoir pouvoir avoir une avance
quand vous allez tirer la dynamique
entre les amuse tout le temps avons une
avance sur les jobs n'avance juge entre
le toit mais avec pétillante en avance
sur l'humanité complète en plus en plus
parce que le chèque le podcast unis
voulu nous entendre josé davantage on
fait des encore moins de filtres à
préchac podcast avec le on vient de
finir de tourner le podcast on va en
jaser on va toucher les nicole non
nicole il est maintenant évident comme
un fils travaille à plat ce détail est
là mais on jase on parle de conversion
qu'on m'aide à voir mais ce si vous
voulez avoir accès
mais heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous c'est exclusif
sur pétillant il faut s'abonner abonnez
vous